Welcome back to civilization Jamie
Kilstein high.
So a lot has changed since the last time
we spoke and for people who don't know,
you used to be the host of or one of the
cohosts of citizen radio,
like Super Progressive Lefty podcast and
you were a Vegan,
but I ate a steak.
Oh,
hell's broken loose.
I don't know what's happening.
I don't know where I am.
Yeah,
I,
I remember I was thinking about like
being back in the studio and uh,
I never met Jamie before and I was like,
all right,
everyone's been really nice to me.
I'm like literally feel like I'm like,
this isn't,
this isn't a trick.
Joe sent me very nice emails and I'm
like,
but I'm a very trickle guy.
Uh,
and I came in and yeah,
everyone's just lovely and nice.
Uh,
yeah man,
a lot of change.
I went into hiding,
hiding
because I only got like a peripheral
story of like what?
What went sideways.
All right.
So like some people girls accused you.
Well,
yeah,
that this is,
look,
this is the fucking worst time for me to
be like,
you know what?
Now that everyone's talking about
Weinstein's time for Kilstein to make
his return,
why too simple.
I like roads.
Yeah.
It's like very,
like Julie and predatory.
When I wrote,
I wrote Stan Hope I get a.
When the wine,
same thing happened.
I was like,
hey man,
you want to like push off this return?
He's like,
you're fine.
Uh,
yeah.
So here's what happened.
So,
uh,
it kind of started where I was a comic a
for years and you know,
as it got more progressive,
um,
it,
it got more into that judgmental
territory I guess where I feel like I
definitely became one of those people
who would just be on twitter all day and
instead of sort of talking about real
issues,
it just becomes like,
who are we mad at that day?
Like,
who used the wrong word that day?
Who can we get fired that day?
And it's twitter mob stuff and it
happens on the right and it happens on
the left.
And it's just like kind of just people
who were sad who just live like in the
box,
which I was like one of them.
Right.
That's fine.
Well,
I think this is such an important
conversation because,
because you've kind of stepped away from
it and you see it for what it is.
I think people don't realize that when
they're caught up in the swirl of it,
the momentum of it,
that it's almost like a natural human
behavior pattern.
It's very tribal.
Yeah.
Well it's tribal and it's physically
addictive.
Um,
you know,
like I've like gone back and forth with
like drinking and not drinking a pot and
not smoking pot.
And I can tell you that the thing I was
addicted to the most was twitter.
It was refreshing twitter.
It was like,
you literally get dopamine hits from
that.
Like I remember when I first tried to
get off twitter,
I like,
I was fighting with some fucking
stranger,
uh,
in my living room on twitter and I was
like,
you know what?
Fuck this.
I'm going to go take a walk.
I don't need a,
I don't need to be involved in this
guy's life.
I closed it and before I even knew it,
I'm like walking in the park,
fighting with some other guy on my
fucking phone and I'm like,
it follows you.
Like if someone's calling you a cunt,
they're calling you a,
of a dinner with your girlfriend,
they're calling you a con when you go to
like your brother's graduation and
you're just like,
refreshing it,
waiting for someone to tell you that
you're good.
Um,
and sort of so that I got addicted to
that,
um,
more than anything.
And especially when I finally got an
audience with the left have left.
Um,
I mean,
just to be very clear,
uh,
it's not like I'm going to come on this
show and suddenly like do a fucking
Shawn michaels.
He'll turn and be like,
I'm Johnny Rape Joke.
Those fucking bitches all had to come
and you're just being a person.
Well,
and that's what I like wasn't doing for
a very long time is I feel like I don't
want to speak for people,
but I feel like with me,
I always needed something to like define
me right.
Where it's like,
I'm a progressive or I'm a,
I'm a Vegan or I'm just Jujitsu and
whatever I whatever I would become kind
of currently obsessed with.
I was sort of like throw the other shit
away and kind of like shit all over that
because,
you know,
a lot of times I would feel like a
failure.
Like that's really where the
progressive.
Um,
I mean I still hold a lot of progressive
ideas,
but that's when I went from comic to the
political.
It wasn't that I like wanted to make
comedy,
my,
my like nemesis,
right.
It was that I felt,
I feel like I've failed.
Um,
you know,
I dropped out of school to start a
comedy like 17 and I did the things
you're supposed to do.
Um,
and yeah,
I did Montreal a couple of times and
Conan once,
uh,
and I had this year where it seemed like
things were gonna happen and then,
you know,
I was kind of that guy that people were
like,
oh,
we like you,
we can't do anything with you but we
like you.
And so I started to kind of make my own
audience.
And the audience was fucking great.
It was like a bunch of,
you know,
when that show started,
it was a bunch of just weird.
I'm sweet,
nerdy comedy fans and then everything
just started getting pushed a to two
crazy though.
Like when I knew shit,
I said this on Doug's podcast when I
knew shit got nuts is when I was
defending a trans person.
So already like a left issue,
like I'm doing the right thing.
Right?
And I called this transphobic,
I an idiot and we get an email that said
a while,
we appreciate you using a defending
trans people.
The word idiot is able list and I want
it to be like,
you're retarded.
Your retarded context.
Okay.
I wanted to list for people,
people making fun of people who don't
know.
I don't know what it means anymore.
I thought abelist was just like,
that guy's in a wheelchair.
Fuck him.
But I guess like all of these different
terms,
these everyday terms,
like I guess idiot is abelist because
fucking,
I don't know.
There was an idiot in a wheelchair.
Oh No,
no,
no.
It's a bliss.
Because if you're not an idiot,
if your brain works well,
you're mocking someone whose brain
doesn't work well.
They're not able to think correct.
You're enabling Joe,
you just out progressive to me.
Well,
I'm pretty progressive.
I know that.
I mean I,
I looked like a meathead and I espoused
some right wing ideas,
but when it comes to like social issues,
I'm very progressive.
We became friends.
You saw a gay rights thing I did on
twitter.
Yeah.
Like you weren't.
That's why I'm.
But I,
but what I saw happening you,
but what I saw happening with you and
what I see happening just in general,
online,
you know,
I mean,
I was on citizens radio when you guys
first started.
You're on our poster.
Yeah.
I think there's something that happened
where people were around the time of
occupy Wall Street.
Things got really heated up and people
started moving way left and then some
folks started moving way.
Right.
And I really truly believe to this day,
the way left is what started the whole
trump movement.
It's in response to the way left.
Yeah.
I think all these shit heads got
together and they didn't like being
accused of being assholes are able lists
or rapist or whatever it is by the ultra
progressives.
So they went far right and all right.
I mean the alt right essentially was
people who didn't identify with these
old men who were bankers,
but they also didn't want to have
anything to do with these ultra lefty
progressive that we're calling everyone
a racist.
Everyone a rapist,
every man's a piece of shit.
Oh,
I,
I did all of that.
Yeah.
I straight up that,
all of that.
And I think one of the things with the,
the ultra left,
and maybe this is me,
like,
uh,
you know,
maybe this is me desperately trying to
defend myself,
but I think in a weird way it was harder
for me and it's harder for a lot of
people to see themselves slipping into
the extreme left.
And so like what I mean by that is I
never thought when I heard people say
the extreme right is as is as bad as the
extreme left.
I was always like,
fuck you.
Because like the extreme left isn't like
the bombing Palestine being like,
give us free healthcare or let Trans
People Piss in the right bathroom,
like,
you know,
uh,
even that like,
the shooter and not in Vegas,
but that DC shooter,
like he was like a fucking crazy guy.
He wasn't able to.
So I'm sorry he wasn't shooting the
politician screaming like,
you know,
I mean he liked the Bernie Sanders page,
but it wasn't like we are launching a
wars against Islam for a Christianity.
It wasn't,
um,
you know,
uh,
what we're doing this for free market
capitalism.
It was,
to me the extreme left when I heard
people say it.
And the reason I would scoff when
someone like you would say it is because
I'm like,
dude,
like the left should just be like,
stand for like,
equality.
Everyone has the right to an education.
Everyone has the right to not go fucking
hungry,
um,
to have health insurance.
I'm gay.
People can do whatever they want with
their dicks than vaginas.
Vaginas.
It shouldn't
be essentially like that on both sides.
The right what,
what being a conservative used to be
with small government and having the
government stay out of your lives and
morphing
where it's like we will stay out of your
lives,
but we will be like in your pussy if you
want a fucking abortion will tell you
like who's Dick you can set up
abortion thing is where it gets real
squirrely.
Right?
Because the abortion thing is
essentially it's a religious thing and
it's a religious thing.
It's and it's a moral thing and it's,
it's also what is an abortion.
I mean you are ending a life but you're
ending a life inside a woman's body.
Well,
when is it okay to do that?
Is it okay to do that
one day and as the grown woman's life
matter more than the cells are more than
me.
Yeah.
That gets to a point,
but initially it's like when is it
defined as a life?
I mean if,
if the moment of conception,
if that moment,
if 30 seconds later it's an abortion,
right?
Like if you could hold your breath and
then the baby's dead.
You know,
like if we found out that the moment
that God comes in a woman,
if she could just hold her breath for a
minute.
Yeah,
I mean is that,
why does that sound worried be murdered?
But.
But it is.
Look,
abortion is fucking weird.
I'm pro choice,
but abortion is weird because like when
you,
when it gets older,
when you're four weeks in,
six weeks in,
it's still illegal and it's a fucking
little baby.
I mean it is a little baby look,
man,
look at it.
It's,
it looks like a little baby.
Sometimes they have a heartbeat.
If it gets to a certain age,
what's going on?
Like I'm not saying that it should be my
choice to define whether or not someone
should do it or not do it,
but it's very disingenuous when people
frame this argument as it's a woman's
right to choose period.
And that's what it is.
It's not just that.
It's also killing a baby.
I don't know.
Man.
Feminists don't like me anymore,
so I'm like,
coat hanger up.
I'm out of this debate.
I don't give a shit.
It's a,
it's a.
It should be an honest debate because it
is a very controversial and very nuanced
issue,
so it's not as simple as,
you know,
the right doesn't want a woman to choose
and stay out of my body.
It's not just stay out of your body.
It's like,
what are we doing?
We're killing a baby that's in a woman's
body.
At what age should that be legal?
Well,
and I think that's the whole thing that
we were talking about before with these
echo chambers where,
you know,
for the first time ever I've been
listening to sort of like both sides of
issues.
Um,
first time ever since recently.
Yay.
Yeah.
Well,
because like you just see again,
the majority of people like,
yeah,
I'll totally fess up.
Sure.
Like I didn't ask a lot of follow up
questions because your facebook feed is
curated and your,
your twitter is all of your friends and
for the most part people you agree with
and you know,
comedy was actually comedy now,
like I've been listening to like a ton
of like backlogs of your show is because
once I was just like,
oh,
he doesn't hit me.
I can listen to the show again.
Great.
Hated.
No,
I know I never hated it.
And so,
uh,
but I started listening to the show and
like hearing pretty equal,
um,
you know,
progressive to conservative ideals and
comedy was always kind of this cool
place where you could explore ideas
because comedy and jokes and laughter
would sort of take the,
um,
take the edge off a little bit,
you know what I mean?
And you could actually talk about issues
and once I kind of became part of that
crew that would um,
even shit on comedy than it was like,
well,
I can watch democracy now and I guess
that's it.
Um,
and I have my.
And I would feel fucking stupid.
I hung out with journalists and hang out
with comics.
I hung out with people where I was sort
of like,
felt like the joke monkey and like,
um,
the high school dropout part of me would
get really like.
But you felt like the job.
Did you feel like you had to be funny
when you're around those pieces?
Because when I tried to say something
like political or that I thought was
smart,
it would just be kind of like a,
a hushed because I'm not that smart.
I'm not,
I'm good at telling stories.
Um,
I'm,
I'm good at like,
I think listening and asking like decent
questions.
Uh,
but I was never like a fucking
intellectual.
Um,
and a lot of that crowd is um,
and that's good.
We need those people,
right?
Um,
but I would,
I,
it was really easy for me to be like,
just shut up,
you know what I mean?
Is this all in your mind?
I mean,
you're a human being,
right?
I mean,
if you're just talking to these people,
you're not an unintelligent person.
No.
Is this just an insecurity that you
carried around with you when you were
around the whole lay?
Um,
yeah,
lot of it was the reason why I asked you
this,
your show was sort of in a lot of ways
of entering into the world of
journalism.
Oh,
so that's right.
It's going,
that's right.
That's where I was going,
like sort of way back,
which was,
um,
you know,
the show,
a show started as a comedy show.
It was called drunk and politics before
it was called citizen radio.
Um,
I think we changed it maybe around like
occupy,
um,
but it was comedy and like we had
progressive ideas.
So that's sort of what we talked about,
but it wasn't that we had to talk about
it became this thing where any
progressive issue in the news that day
or on twitter we had to,
we had to talk about that day and um,
it's sort of lost.
I don't know.
Did you,
did it also interrupt interrupting here,
but did it also,
you,
you guys went to is sort of a
subscription service?
No,
we actually,
um,
you know,
that
I think I'm really proud of about that
show and why I'm definitely bummed out.
I lost,
um,
a lot of those fans are or whatever was
we.
We started ages ago.
We,
uh,
we were pretty early on with podcasts
and we never had commercials and we
never had.
You didn't really get anything if you
paid.
It was voluntary,
it was like a shitty version of NPR
where it was like everybody gets to show
for free.
Right.
It was like I was trying to be
socialist.
Everyone gets to show for free if you
can't afford $5 a month,
$10 a month,
$50.
People do that way.
Sam Harris does that.
Totally.
Yeah.
We just didn't really have,
like,
we couldn't afford to send you like a
tote bag or whatever,
but yeah.
So it wasn't a pay model.
Everything said anybody could
hear.
Um,
we occasionally did like little,
like goofy bonus shows for like
subscribers,
but that was it.
That was the question.
So there was some shows that only people
who subscribed because not a lot though.
Yeah.
And it was five days a week too,
so it was a lot.
That's another thing when you're doing
the fucking show five days a week,
you got to dig for things to be like,
pissed off about a.
to not be redundant.
Yeah.
I've done five days a week shows and uh,
I don't think I'm at my best five days a
week.
I think four days a week is where I
start to break down anything after four
days a week unless I'm doing like fight
companions,
which are just a goof that's just
hanging out,
watching fights.
That's easy.
Yeah.
You don't want to get stale board.
You don't want to force it into being a
job.
No.
I think what I got out of you was that
you or you were getting a lot of praise
and you were.
You were being hailed like I saw Jessica
Bell wrote something where they called
you a great example of an ally or that
was pre this year.
He has a bell.
Yeah,
but I mean,
but that expression was a.
is a very odd expression.
I mean,
I hate to sound like this is
disingenuous egalitarianism,
but I really do believe this.
I mean we.
We should be allies to each other.
We all should be this idea that like
there's a God team war going on that
Jamie Kilstein is out there booking for
the females.
That's what it's like.
It's like that's what they input.
They reward that.
This is the thing.
It's like some,
and this is not the single outage as
well because I think they've got some
great writers.
There's,
there's something that happens with
people when you write a lot of mean a
very critical stuff and you you become
this,
this attack machine and this is how you
promote your ideas.
This is how you push your agenda by
attacking people that some of them
fucking deserve it for sure.
Some of them we're definitely assholes,
but it becomes almost like the currency
that you're dealing.
Yeah,
and that goes back to the insecurity,
right?
By the way,
my,
but let me finish sentence is that when,
when you're an attack machine like that,
and not saying that Jezza bill,
but there's a lot of the blogs that are
attack machines when you're attacked
machine and if you can be an ally on the
other side are not even on the other
side,
but an ally to the attack machine like
and then they single you out,
is that it gives you this feeling like,
oh,
I'm not going to get attacked by them.
This is good,
and you reinforce that behavior by
ramping up.
The types of things that you say that
they like,
they appreciate and it becomes a sort of
weird exchange where you know,
it's like imply like I think this is
what a lot of what goes on and political
circles as well.
Like there's not as much bribery as
there is an understanding that if you do
what we want you to do and you say what
we want you to do,
then you're in,
then you're on the good side.
Yeah.
And that goes back to that insecurity
and I think a lot of people are
insecure.
I think we're all
Everyone is.
And when you do find that tribe.
Yes.
And you do find people who are going.
Yeah.
And the more you attack on twitter
because not just blogs,
like remember,
like individuals on twitter,
like me,
like when I would see like who's getting
piled on today.
Okay,
cool.
This writer wrote something about
mansplaning don't need to read the
article.
What's the Hashtag?
That's the Hashtag.
I'm going to say the fucking meanest
funny thing because I'm a comic and I'm
funnier than journalists and then a
famous people are going to retweet me or
phase me and then I get to feel like a
fucking civil rights hero because that's
what,
what happened where like I would
literally tweet even if not even a joke,
even if I tweeted somebody's sincere and
this like sucks to admit,
but even if I tweeted something like
Hashtag black lives matter,
I'm refreshing that shit to be like to
Queslo favorite.
You know what I mean?
Like I'm not doing it to be,
you know,
and then you can feel good about
yourself.
Then you can go.
Not Saying I did this,
but you can go on the street and you can
fucking ignore the homeless person and
you can cross the street when you see
like the scary black guy because you're
just like,
well,
I'm technically the Rosa Parks of
twitter because I fucking tweeted that
joke at that writer who said that
fucking thing that no one's going to
remember tomorrow,
but we were all angry about today.
Jesus Christ.
This is the first time I've had caveman
coffee.
Oh,
there's Nitros are no joke,
drinking adderall.
I think I've ever done adderall.
But
uh,
I got adderall offered to me before the
Stan hope podcast and he came up to me
afterwards and was like,
ah man,
you fucking talked a lot.
That adderall fucked you up.
And I was like,
I didn't take it like I had it in my
pocket.
It's like,
that was just me being spazzy.
Um,
so I think what happens is,
so yeah,
so you get that validation
validation and it's essentially,
it's an exchange and it was an exchange
that you're talking about with twitter
being like this.
You get this dopamine rush every time
you tweet and refresh.
And it's one of the main reasons why I
don't interact with people online very
much.
It's very rare that I do.
And when I do,
I'm almost always civil.
Yeah.
Because I just don't think that unless
it's.
One of my friends called Berta fucking
door because he called himself.
The machine is like,
come on dude,
I'm the machine.
Like I love him so much years ago.
Let that go.
Bird got to move on.
I uh,
but I mean that's just fake.
No,
no.
And I,
um,
I wasn't gonna say off that with man.
Just a sort of sidebar with twitter when
all that shit happened to me and I got
off all social media but you didn't
explain what happened.
Oh,
right,
right.
Um,
okay.
So you're the Super Vegan fet,
the feminists too.
Feminists and again,
like the ideas at their core,
right is bad rape,
sped,
like these shouldn't be fucking
controversial issues,
but when you take it to that extreme,
um,
that you were talking about where you're
looking to sort of like,
who can I call a sexist today?
Who can I call it racist today
thing?
It's like,
it's,
it becomes an attack machine.
Yeah.
And uh,
yeah,
my,
my dad said that yesterday.
He's like,
you go on the show,
you should say you're not going to be an
attack machine.
And I'm like,
what a Dorky thing to say.
I swear to God,
I emailed it to myself.
It can be like Brogan,
degrade you year.
And My pops.
Yeah,
he's gonna be very excited.
Um,
so yeah,
so that happened and what you were
saying with the allied title,
I was never comfortable with a lot of
the,
the stuff I got thrown into,
um,
you know,
I was constantly saying either the wrong
or offensive things on the show that we
would have to do to try and be funny
because I'm trying to be funny and we're
going to have to stop and edit it out
and I would feel like a fucking idiot.
And um,
and I remember I did a college once and
it was the first time it's ever
happened.
Like usually they,
you know,
they introduce you by my measly credits,
like they would be like,
he did Conan once and this time the,
the woman at the college introduced me.
She didn't give any comedy credits.
She just goes out.
Our headliner tonight is a male feminist
and I remember going into the mic and
being like,
that makes me sound like a rapist.
Like it sounds so fucking creepy.
And that's what I was like labeling
myself.
That was a label that was thrown at me
and in my head I'm like,
well,
I don't hate women.
So I guess.
Sure.
Um,
but male feminists sounds like you're
like cruising around in like a fucking
male feminist van being like,
who wants equal pay?
Like it sounds so creepy,
but I,
I took it because there is so much
sexism on the other side that you're
like,
I guess man,
I guess being an ally is good,
right?
That's like you're defending people,
but then it gets to this level where
you're like,
I got to renew my ally dues and call
somebody a fucking rapist.
Um,
and that's where it got stuck.
So.
And then this,
so this is where it bit me in the ass.
So I come on this show,
we have the argument about a sexism
like,
right.
I had,
we had a discussion about Daniel Tosh
rape jokes when Daniel Tosh made a rape
jokes.
And,
and also there was this,
this weird definition that people like
to use in a term.
I'm sure you're probably aware of the
actual definition now of like how many
rapes actually occur,
which is it.
It all came from a study that I want,
if I want to say it was out of the
University of Arizona,
but I forget where the study was,
but they essentially looked at almost
any uncomfortable interaction between a
man and a woman.
Unwanted or remorseful sex was rape a
lot,
a lot of different things.
Sex while intoxicated was raped.
There's a lot of different things that
they use to define sex where they got to
this one and five.
Well,
and this is another reason we need to
have the conversation,
right?
Because like I'm remorseful.
I don't know what that definition is,
but that doesn't sound like many people
have had sex.
I'm sure you have in the afterwards like
what the.
Some people want to call that rape,
but like a,
if you're a fucking blackout drunk and
like the dude's not like.
Right,
okay.
That is.
But if we can't have the conversation
and the girl's not,
you get raped.
Right.
Because that's happened to me.
That's happened to me too.
Yeah,
I'm straight up.
Has it grover hit you.
Hit me physically.
I had girl swinging at me.
I got the Telegraph it,
do they wind up and,
and they're,
and they're yelling,
which I've been told that's what they
tell you to do on Krav Maga.
Uh,
but they yell while they do and I'm
like,
no,
you can't yell before you throw a punch.
I'm going to come coming.
Uh,
but these are stories that like I
couldn't even tell it.
Like I had a girlfriend tried to beat
the shit out of me,
uh,
when I was,
when I was like 20 years old,
but it happened at the same time.
So I swear to God I,
I'm just dodging what happened but I
will get through it after this.
Um,
I,
uh,
she was breaking up with her but it was
at the same time that,
um,
do you remember dyphus?
There was like child services,
typhus,
that's what,
that was the acronym,
like,
I don't know,
maybe it's just like a Jersey thing,
but it was child services essentially
was at our house to do like an
inspection essentially to be like,
is it fit to have kids here?
Um,
because like my house was a disaster
back in the day.
They do it in.
Were you guys thinking about having a
baby?
No,
no,
no.
We had like a alcoholism in the family
and neighbors were complaining and
screaming and like I was a fucking train
wreck.
And um,
oh,
I was like,
oh no,
I guess I was like 19,
but I was still living at home.
Um,
and I'm one of five,
so I'm the oldest of five.
So this guy.
So I'm breaking up with my girlfriend
not knowing that this,
like dyphus random inspection is going
to happen and this guy comes over and
he's just like older African guy and
he's sitting with my dad on the couch,
African American or African African,
African.
And uh,
so the accident and every,
that's the one,
uh,
I'm allowed to laugh at that now.
Good Times.
I,
yeah,
I can.
There's so many words I can say now.
It's a good time to be alive word.
Oh my God.
I was with my friend the first time I
hung out with a comic,
uh,
this guy,
Louis Gomez,
do,
you know,
so it was with Louis and we were hanging
out in la and I was telling him I think
I want to do comedy again.
And He,
he made a joke with the word fingering
in it and I started laughing like a
fucking kid and I'm like,
I forgot how fucking funny the word
fingering is a funny word.
I felt like I came out of like a comedy
coma.
I was like,
oh,
fingering and midget and Co,
like,
there's so many good.
Anyway,
so,
so my girlfriend,
so I'm breaking up with her and she
starts swinging at me and she's like,
you can't fucking break up with me,
like blah,
blah blah.
And I was just like,
I was like,
Hey,
we can talk about this later.
But like there's a guy downstairs who is
going to a,
with a hilarious,
who's going to take like take my
brother,
she,
you have to like stop and she's fucking
swing and swing at me.
Nope.
And she's screaming.
She was,
she was like,
are he used to beat the shit out of her?
And then she has bell wrote about it and
that's what happened.
Um,
so I'm just like,
kind of like covering up and I'm like,
you have to stop.
They're going to take my baby brother.
She storms off.
I go downstairs and this guy from child
services is there.
And I looked at him and I have tears in
my eyes and I'm like,
please don't take my brother's,
like,
she doesn't live here,
she's just my girlfriend.
I broke up with her,
she's never going to be here again.
Like I'm so sorry about that.
And he just looks me and he goes out and
my dad and it just goes,
women are crazy,
aren't they?
And I was just like,
all right.
And that was it.
He didn't give a fuck.
He was like,
I've seen that before.
And like,
she got to leave.
Yeah,
it was lucky.
I got lucky.
Been an angry woman.
Could have been angry woman and we all
would have been in jail.
Um,
okay.
So I am known as this male feminist.
Um,
which again,
um,
and it kind of becomes my thing.
So I go on your show.
We argue about it because I'm like,
I don't have comic friends anymore.
Uh,
so,
uh,
I,
I take this side,
um,
and I didn't hear all about the rape
joke.
Like I just heard all the whole Daniel
tosh story.
I heard,
uh,
at the Stan hope show for the first time
because the articles I read don't have
the nuanced parts,
right?
So all I explain what actually have.
Sure.
Daniel Tosh was not supposed to be on
stage that night.
Daniel Tosh was just hanging out at the
laugh factory and his good friend Dom,
I asked him to go up and he said,
I'll go,
okay,
I don't have any to talk about.
He goes on stage.
Everybody goes crazy.
Oh my God,
Daniel Tosh is here.
This is amazing.
And he goes,
look,
he goes,
I don't have any material,
I'm not even supposed to be up here.
So what do you guys want to talk about?
What you know in some guy yells out.
And he goes,
yeah.
He goes,
yeah,
that's real funny sir.
Well,
what's funny about rape?
The humiliation of violence and this
woman yells out,
actually,
nothing's funny about rape,
like very self aggrandizing.
And he goes,
wouldn't be funny.
And five guys raped her right now like
that.
That's the funny part is like what a
comedian does.
So that line was the line that was
circulating.
But even that first part,
not that that part was ignored
conveniently,
the whole part where he's just like,
what's funny about it?
And like that's a good.
Technically that's an anti rape joke,
right?
Um,
and you know,
Daniel,
that's how he thinks he's not,
he's not a bad guy.
No sense the one,
that's a great way,
but that has to do with these echo
chambers where I'm like,
why don't fucking hear that part of it?
Um,
I just hear the part,
you just hear the part that you're
supposed to attack.
And then,
you know,
ironically I went to one of Burt's
podcasts,
uh,
at the same festival,
the all things comedy festival and
fucking Doug and burt,
like this whole rape thing happened in
the audience.
I don't know if you heard about it,
but like,
all hell broke loose in the audience
with that.
So like,
uh,
I don't want to be the one to blow up
the spot.
I don't know if birds going to aerate,
if he's gonna,
if he,
if he hears the take off from work
podcast or whatever,
it's one of the best things I've ever
heard.
But this,
we call them right now.
Yeah.
Because I don't want to blow up his
spot.
But essentially what happened was they
stand hope it'll just get people to
listen.
Good.
Stan hope started,
uh,
talking about a rape and child rape and
the whole show became very rape themed.
Right?
And there was a girl next to me and
there was a woman next to me and my
girlfriend who just started screaming
like Dell talk about it.
And like I said,
they ignored her the whole time.
Um,
and my girlfriend and I would look over
and then she would like have another sip
of her drink and watch show and giggle
and then rape
will come up.
But she was like stopped.
We just screamed.
But like she didn't,
she didn't,
she didn't leave,
like she didn't get up and leave.
And that was like,
it was so interesting to be on sort of
the opposite end of that where,
you know,
nothing offensive was really happening
and I'm like,
fuck man,
I,
I'm next to that lady from the show.
This is,
this is like my Karmic fate and I'm just
like,
she should go,
she should leave.
But anyway,
so I was on the not calm,
excited of that.
And by then I wasn't doing comedy clubs,
I was never really accepted into comedy
clubs.
I'm just playing for my progressive
audience.
Said like a Vegan coffee house.
Like that's,
I'm just playing random,
like little rock gigs for like my
audience.
So again,
Echo Chamber,
right?
And I'm not hanging out with comics.
So when people were like,
why aren't you defending a comment?
And I'm like,
I don't know man,
because I don't think I am one.
Like I didn't,
I,
I didn't really consider myself one.
And so,
um,
yeah.
So me and you a me and you went at it.
I believe it was very divisive.
I think half your audience thought I was
a,
a whiny bitch and the other half thought
I was a whiny bitch,
you should get raped.
Uh,
it was very one sided.
Nobody liked me.
I was uh,
I did not come off well,
I'm told and,
but I was like,
I guess I did the right thing,
right.
I guess I sided with women over over a
jokes.
And so from then on,
any comic that did like Mei didn't,
uh,
let me stop you right there.
Yeah.
Just,
and I'm not trying to sound the same to
me by the way.
Yeah,
the sake of honesty,
the real issue came not just because of
that,
but because of your characterization the
next day.
Yeah,
totally.
So the next day there's a video out
about it that someone put together
called the Kilstein delusion and some of
that shit was taken out of context.
Some of that shit I will
completely like own up to.
I watched it like once,
I mean at that point,
that point,
uh,
just all hell broke loose.
Like I lost my,
I lost my managers.
I love was having like a,
someone hacked my twitter and just wrote
rape all over.
It was kind of like,
did you lose your manager?
Uh,
they said it was because I don't
cooperate with the comedy community.
Uh,
to be fair to them.
I was like a pain in the ass client.
It was hard enough for me to fucking
book and then every complicates me and
they're like,
I don't know man.
I think they just like threw their hands
up.
Um,
and so the next day was one of those
things where I'm like,
I either doubled down and like,
and I was like,
it wasn't like I'm like,
I'm going to lie.
It was,
I'm gonna try to uh,
defend myself and give,
like,
you know,
my side to it and that I don't know,
it wouldn't stop you here real quick
because we're going way,
way,
way back.
The real issue.
This is like a year before,
more than a year before everything went
sideways.
Oh yeah.
Hey,
what went sideways and why?
So you're this Super Progressive Vegan
guy,
but what went sideways?
So,
so I'm an ex of mine,
um,
an ex of mine,
uh,
I'm trying to think about like how much
I can say,
um,
started.
Um,
it was weird like girls I was dating,
like she would kind of like pop up and
be like following them on like social
media and I kind of was like,
all right,
it's a little weird.
But you were married at the time.
So what was also not talked about in
these articles is that for the last
however many years before I'm out and I
got separated,
we were in an open relationship.
We just didn't,
we talked about it on the show
eventually,
but for awhile we didn't talk about it.
Um,
and which to anyone in a fucking open
relationship,
like it's a nightmare when you're not
talking about it because you feel like,
uh,
a lecherous cheating creep a because
you're in an open relationship.
I mean,
you don't talk about it.
So then when girls meet you and you tell
them,
I'm like,
yeah,
right.
Yeah,
totally.
When you go home in a secret open
relationship,
you're like,
you're full of shit.
Um,
and so,
you know,
I like Kinda did the road thing but like
felt like a fucking creep and rotary
meaning hookup with girls and uh,
and then uh,
you know,
I was finally just like,
we have to talk about it and at this
point,
and I don't want to shit on anybody,
uh,
you know,
at this point,
um,
you know,
my cohost then I,
we were like,
we were pretty much just like really
good friends,
right?
Who lived together and did a show
together.
And I'm so years later,
years after me and this girl broke up
years after all this shit,
I'm living in La.
Um,
I have a guy had a girlfriend for a
year.
It's like a very healthy,
wonderful relationship.
Um,
years after all this.
I guess what happened was one of these
girls,
I'm essentially started to try to find
any girl who has been pissed off by me
before and they found enough for an
article that,
um,
I think like two articles came out.
I left to do some radio because the show
was getting a ton of complaints because
our inner circles started to find out
that the record unquote accusations,
which the word accusation makes it sound
Weinstein.
Um,
accusations of.
So that's what they were saying.
But there was,
it was very unspecific.
What I've read,
they said predatory behavior.
And I was like,
oh,
meaning he's trying to get laid.
That's what a man does.
Not Predatory in the sense of you're
victimizing someone to raping someone or
doing something horrible to someone.
Or even,
and this is when my own words kind of
bit me in the ass because you,
I spent an entire year a or years being
like,
you know,
a Hashtag believed women.
And then you read that and you go,
ah,
Hashtag don't believe women.
Like,
you don't know what to do.
And like I,
I was always like,
if you call a girl who accuses you,
uh,
you know,
crazy,
you're just projecting and like you're
trying to.
And then suddenly I'm reading this
article,
I'm like,
this is fucking crazy.
And I didn't,
uh,
all of my stuff in one article you talk
about the,
yeah,
there was Jenzabar article and Hell hath
no fury like a woman scorned.
I,
uh,
it was really bad and I read it for the
first time and I don't want to go into
details because I don't want to shit on
people who like,
feel like they were,
um,
you know,
hurt or whatever.
Um,
but a good majority of the article isn't
even fucking true.
Um,
there was one part where Jezza bell even
wrote it.
Like if we can make it about journalism
Jenzabar because it's one woman who
wrote it.
Oh yeah.
Totally.
So this,
so the author,
there's one moment in it and I'll try to
make this about journalism and not about
the,
the woman,
but one of the complaints about me was I
had a consensual night with a lady in
Nashville,
um,
who I guess because she listened to the
show,
maybe they're like,
that's predatory because you're like
famous.
And I was like,
well,
no one else thinks I'm fucking famous.
Uh,
wait a minute,
wait a minute.
There were defining as predatory because
you're famous.
That's part of it.
Every time Mick Jagger gets laid,
it's predatory.
That's part of it.
That's what I don't.
That's the thing.
And by the way,
fucking call me.
If I'm Mick Jagger famous,
you can call me a fucking Predator if
I'm,
I can barely get a plus one to have
vegan festival famous like,
don't please do not call me a predator.
I mean,
look,
it's,
there's levels to fame,
right?
And I know you're being self deprecating
and everything like that,
but you did have a nice following and
you did.
I saw some of your videos online.
We did big crowds.
So it's not,
no,
it's not like you didn't have fans know
she did that fans,
but the idea that you liking some woman
who's a fan and her liking you somehow
know that you're a Predator because she
enjoys your work is crazy.
Was that how they were defining it?
Because I don't know.
And then,
but then it seems like they've been very
convenient.
Their definition.
Well,
and that was part of it.
There was a,
um,
there was another one where it was like,
yeah,
the predatory stuff specifically was
that.
And then what was even more fucked up
about the article was it said,
um,
and,
and I'm not going to quote exactly.
She also wrote into another podcast and
I heard this,
but essentially what the woman said,
we did not sleep together.
It alluded that we slept together.
It didn't say that I was in an open
relationship,
but we didn't sleep together.
Um,
she told me she didn't want to,
uh,
sleep together.
And I was like,
great,
no problem.
She's like,
I don't want,
I don't want it to go further than that,
you know?
So I was like,
cool.
Even if you change your mind,
we're not going to do it.
Got It.
And then in the article in the article
about me being a Predator,
it's like I felt so safe and,
and,
and it was a great night and I was like,
this sounds like an article about pep
and a good dude.
And then it said,
but then weeks later she heard on the
podcast that she was just a road fuck.
And then rebel in parentheses is one,
Arthur Arthur from Isabel and fantasy
said Jezza bell could not find the clip,
right?
Because it doesn't fucking exist because
I'm not going to call someone a road
fuck next to my wife on my feminist
podcast.
Not only that,
you're not going to say it if you didn't
even have sex with them.
We didn't have sex.
Right?
So this is just,
they just decided to take this
characterization by this one woman did
in flavor the article.
Yes.
It's very unfair.
And Dude,
like,
is this punishment you think for you
because you somehow or another.
So that's why it becomes easy.
And,
and just to be like incredibly clear,
like if this woman was like hurt by
that,
that sucks man.
I've been burned by girls can do
anything if she didn't,
if she was hurt because you didn't
eventually become her girlfriend,
her boyfriend rather.
That's just on her.
Sure.
Unless you're mischaracter no,
no,
no.
It's,
I'm just trying to be.
You're trying to be nice.
That'd be nice.
Yeah.
Well I assume she is probably,
you know,
she's probably taken out of context as
well.
There's a real problem with writing
things about people and one of the real
problems with writing things about
people is they don't get a chance to
respond in real time to things you're
saying.
So you establish a narrative and then
you keep going with it.
You write paragraph after paragraph with
no,
no one responding to them months later.
I counter to,
I saw like the,
the,
the woman who wrote the article,
like there was a request in my like
other inbox and facebook that like you
don't even see it and like for a
comment.
So like,
I mean I got,
she did reach out,
but at that point I was a,
at that point I was literally googling
ways to kill myself.
So I'm like,
I did,
I did not get back to googling ways to
kill yourself for real.
Yeah,
for real.
So we'll just to like why put it on the
article?
So here's what happened,
and this goes to your question before
because I had called so many people
sexist because I had sort of made my
almost career by that.
Um,
it was fucking fun man.
When people heard about this like,
and you see the headlines and this is
another problem with like click bait
journalism.
The headlines look like I was fucking
accused of rape.
There was a one article that used the
word sexual harassment.
Sexual misconduct was in all the
headlines.
What is that?
I,
I've seen that one about people
connected to Harvey Weinstein,
like about Ben Affleck,
they called it sexual misconduct.
What does that mean?
Like,
but in something that you don't think
they should do,
what's really creepy?
Eagle and I almost lost a job.
I did just lose a gig because when you
google and be like sexual misconduct
stuff and like that's really a scary and
again,
I don't want to be like,
you know who the real victim of Harvey
Weinstein is?
Jamie Kilstein.
But like,
uh,
let me just stop you right here.
If you say like one more time,
I fucking head's going to explode dude.
I get comments like that.
It's brutal.
It's a brutal.
Isn't as bad as.
All right.
I'm going to,
I just want you to slow it down.
I'm going to use it every now and then.
Flip this coffee over here.
Breaking like the light meter.
I'm gonna.
Do it to men.
A lot of people do it.
It's an easy one to do.
I'm going to hit switched to water,
but that word is a,
it's an,
it's a.
people use it as um,
I know,
I know.
It's okay.
I do it too.
We all do it,
but it's just,
it's nice to know.
Yeah,
no,
I,
it's also a very progressive thing.
Like there's a way that people talk,
like when they're really progressive
that like you don't hear like left wing
people talk.
I keep getting fucked over by the
progressive's.
It's a way of appearing.
What's the word?
Submissive or passive?
Yeah.
It's not a,
it's not an aggressive way of
communicating.
All right.
What if I said like,
but like I kept punching the table like
as I did it on a fucking like,
you know,
like go to like step to me just smash up
perhaps a can.
So.
So you got a bunch of people that were
upset at you because you had embodied
the quintessential allies.
So it was there.
Nobody had a reason to like me or to
defend me.
On one half of the twittersphere you had
progressives who thought I was a sexual
creep.
And then on the other half you have
comedy fans who are like,
fuck this dude.
He's the one who called everyone a
sexist.
You don't need to read the article.
If you see a headline.
I mean,
God,
I attacked so many people without
fucking reading the articles.
Of course there are people to this day
that will come up on citizen radio that
I don't know why I was mad at.
I would just figure out the story as we
were covering it and be like,
Yep,
fuck that guy.
I guess of course.
And so nobody.
There was no reason to root for me.
There wasn't a strong enough fan base.
It wasn't like if,
you know,
a bigger comic gets accused of
something.
Well he has thousands or millions of
fans and then this small community who
accused him of something I had sort of
nobody and when I burnt all the bridges
and in comedy and you know,
I never just showed up at clubs to do
sets and stuff like that.
I just had this audience and sort of
thought I could never get fired,
you know,
like when,
when Allie and I sort of became more
platonic before the open relationship.
I mean there were days it was,
it was.
So,
uh,
you know,
I mean I would sleep on the couch,
but there were days I would go on the
road and I would not cheat and I would
go back to the hotel and shirk off and
like my orgasm was better because I'm
like,
I saved citizen radio.
Like I was trying so hard not to,
not to do anything like that.
And so anyway,
I lost.
Yeah,
there was no one to root for me.
I just had this small audience.
A small audience either thinks I'm a
Predator or they're too nervous to say
anything.
Well,
you fit the quintile,
you,
there's a classic view of what a male
feminist is in that classic view is a
sneaky guy that is like getting in tight
with women and saying all the things
they really want to hear.
And the classic story is that those
women are never attracted to that guy
anyway.
And one up and go and fuck some jocks.
I'm Alpha Guy.
I didn't mean that's literally what
happened was like,
yeah,
you don't say like,
do you?
But it's just this thing that people,
there's,
it's just.
Well,
it's a cliche and I totally,
and I also think it was the homophobic
politician who sucks a Dick,
right?
Where they're like the super religious
guy who turns out to actually be gay.
Like Ted,
what is that guy's name?
The guy from Colorado.
Can we just say careers and started?
You probably couldn't,
right?
It was definitely a price.
Yeah.
And so haggard Ted Haggard.
Yes.
Yeah.
And the Chinese have a bit about them
and who didn't.
And so this is what happens.
Yeah.
This is sort of the problem with acting
like you don't have flaws.
And I always did.
I thought on the show,
my favorite parts of my show were when I
talked about a depression or alcoholism
and,
and we would get emails in from people
who said it really helped them and I
wanted to talk so much about that stuff
because I,
I do think it's important to examine
your flaws,
but on a political level,
I held myself up as like an untouchable.
I think you were doing essentially the
same thing that you were talking about
doing on twitter where you're addicted
to this positive response and you're
addicted to saying these things about
people and attacking people there.
It's a real problem on the left where
there are people that essentially a
giant majority of what they do is
attacking people.
Yeah.
And you also get scared about what you
can talk about.
So one of the things that would come up
a lot was like fat shaming stories on
the show,
but what also came up was like I fucking
loved Jujitsu and so we would get emails
from people who are like,
Yo,
my doctor just said like I have to lose
weight or I'm fucked or whatever.
And the first thing I would recommend,
like I would give that advice and I
would be like Jujitsu,
go fucking do Jujitsu.
And then we got countless emails from
people who are like,
Yo,
I lost 100 pounds because I did Jujitsu.
I just got my blue belt.
Like I feel confident for the first time
or whatever.
And then we would get emails,
a counter emails being like,
I don't want you to talk about that
because that's fat shaming to me.
And I couldn't say that's fucking crazy.
I couldn't say,
why couldn't you say that?
Because it would be fetching it in the
box that I had put myself in.
I couldn't say that I was capable of
saying it.
I thought it.
I set it off the air.
Can you see this is where it gets real
problematic when it comes to expressing
your ideologies.
Like if you can't be honest about your
actual thoughts,
then what you're doing is bullshit
bullshit.
And there is a,
the the other side to the validation of
ones you find yourself in a box is the,
is the policing of it.
So there's validation on one side and
then there's,
Oh,
I can get kicked out on the other side.
Right?
Like if I say this word,
I can get kicked out if I say that.
Like you should not fucking come down on
someone for doing Jujitsu and getting
into better shape than you.
If you don't want to do it.
I'm not saying this guy is doing
Jujitsu,
so fuck you for being fat.
I'm saying this guy's doing Jujitsu.
We should be proud of this guy who saved
his life.
That's not fat shaming.
And there's so much of that projection
from the left were [inaudible] on
twitter in general where it's like,
why is that though?
I mean it,
it really is the ideology thing.
So like you are unable to criticize
anyone that's in your team because this
is essentially what's going on.
So they're using the phrase fat shaming,
which is obviously a progressive
ideology or it fits right into it.
But for someone to say that you're fat
shaming by discussing people
successfully managing their health,
that's fucking intense where it gets
crazy.
But if you,
if you wanted to,
you wanted to talk about.
Of course I did.
Allison,
who as well?
Um,
I mean I can't speak for her.
Right?
But you guys have conversations off the
air about what this is crazy would have
conversations about that.
And uh,
you know,
because you don't.
Because fat shaming sex,
right?
Like if someone gets fired for being
like,
that's the thing.
I think there's a middle ground,
so slippery road when you can honestly
communicate and this is what the debate
side gets silenced.
It's done.
And that's what happens with,
you know,
I was listening to a,
I think it was Sam's podcast with the
guy who got screened off of that campus.
Sam Harris,
Jordan Peterson maybe.
Oh No,
no.
The guy that was a halloween costume
wise,
um,
the,
uh,
from it was him and his wife and he was
just like,
sounded like the sweetest guy.
Great.
Good.
I just knew,
I was like,
I fucking,
I don't remember when,
but I can guarantee there's an episode
about that guy was just like,
I was defending my wife.
I'm,
I've given to progressive causes my
whole life.
I just tried to talk to them and yeah,
he would raise his hand and they would
call it like a fucking,
some kind of like microaggression or,
or I don't,
I don't even remember what,
you know,
what happened to evergreen,
evergreen steaks.
I heard it on your show.
It was,
yeah.
Oh yeah,
I did hear that episode.
Yeah.
That's a,
that's a very extreme example.
What they were telling the president to
put his hands down.
That's what I said,
because you are making these,
this,
you're being aggressive with your hands.
So he did put his hands down and they
started laughing because that's what's
really going on.
It's a game.
Well,
and the thing is too,
it's like we have such legit racism and
sexism in this country and I feel like
we should be going after those issues.
Right.
Well that's why I think you are.
This conversation is very important
because you are an example of someone
who got caught up in the ideology of
things where your intentions were good
in the beginning,
but you got caught up in this whole
leftwing spiral.
Yeah.
That's the thing is if you go extreme,
right?
I feel like,
you know,
if I had like a big,
like Nazi kill the Jews,
like closing prop bit.
I feel like I would know I was selling
out,
you know,
but on the left it's a creep man because
you really feel like,
again,
the baseline of homophobia is bad.
Sexism is bad,
racism is bad.
Those are good things.
Right?
So when it starts to creep into the
language policing and stuff like that,
at least for me,
I didn't really
notice it.
I would notice it sometimes and be like,
man,
I wish I could say this and I wouldn't
because I wouldn't wanna get in trouble
and it bit me in the ass anyway.
And you know.
So the suicide stuff was like,
yeah,
like I had,
I had nothing people on twitter stopped
doing shows.
Oh,
I stopped,
I got a day job for the first time in
like 15.
What are you doing for a living years?
A jujitsu stuff.
Um,
and uh,
you know,
but even this stuff like I don't want to
put that fucking job is in jeopardy.
Right?
Like at least it's something I love and,
but yeah,
I couldn't perform.
I didn't because again,
remember,
like,
so you felt like your audience was gone?
Audience gone.
Oh,
straight up.
I mean there was a facebook comment,
I just stopped going online,
but there was a facebook comment from
the day before there was like,
just so you know,
you saved me from killing myself.
And then the next day when all that shit
broke loose,
like you know,
you can like add a comment to your
comment.
It was like,
fuck you,
I hope you whatever.
Same dude like literally added it to his
comment,
but you need to think about some of the
things that you said and realized that
you didn't really mean them,
but you were saying them because you
want your trading in the currency of
political,
correct,
left wing,
progressive ideology thinking.
Right?
And you were,
you were getting from that.
But you gotta realize these other people
are doing the same thing.
Like they don't really mean what they're
saying.
They feel like they have to say,
fuck you.
I hope you die.
Jamie Kilstein.
They don't even know you well.
I think we have a real problem both left
and right in this country with attacking
people.
And I hate to say this,
but I think we have a problem with doing
that with trump because although he has
done some reprehensible things and he
said some really foolish things and his
ego is ridiculous.
There's a lot of things wrong with him.
Right?
But the,
the attacks on him at all this attacking
instead of sort of laying out a better
way instead of explaining what's wrong
with it,
it's all insulting and attacking that
doesn't fix anything and it's not
going to.
And it also is going to make his people
double down and they're not gonna want
to listen to it either.
My point.
And that's what I.
that's what I noticed.
That's why you never want a twitter
argument.
Right?
Do you have like extreme one side,
an extreme other side is like,
cool,
you're gonna solve this in 140
characters.
That's right.
The problem is also people start
insulting each other.
It just doesn't work.
It doesn't yet.
It becomes a contest.
It's like you try to do that and I go
check and then you go check and then we
move in back and forth and you're trying
to fucking get.
Yeah.
And then like people's twitter bios or
like their whole bio or like here's a
list of people who blocked me.
It's like Yo man,
if that's your fucking,
that's your resume,
that's your life accolades.
Like that's such a bummer.
And I wouldn't have people block me and
I never even communicated with them
because I somehow or another I got on
some sort of a list or someone decided
that was about a guy I use that and I
don't
know how to reverse it because now,
uh,
I'm friends with allegiance escape guys.
And I was like,
oh,
I think I blocked everyone.
It's called like twitter,
blockchain or something.
And so I would go to your profile if
like all of your fans are attacking me.
And I'm like,
fuck this,
uh,
I go to your profile and then I click
it.
And it blocks everyone who follows you
a,
it's not just that like people,
there's,
there's groups that people have decided,
I've seen that,
that,
that they decide you're right wing
decide your anti progressive or
whatever.
I'm like,
I hate lesson blocked by people that
were like,
I never even communicated with this
person.
It's like a screenshot of someone's
saying something absolutely ridiculous.
And I'll go,
oh my God,
I got to go to this guy's page.
Yeah.
And then I go there was on block,
which by the way you fucking dummies.
Oh you have to do is sign out of 20 and
then I go to your page and then I read
it all can't really block someone.
Like what?
I know what I found myself,
like looking through all those.
I was like fuck out of this.
So I,
I will say cautionary tale.
Oh my God,
I will.
That's going to be what my Edinburgh
show is called a cautionary Beta male
tail.
Are you going to do?
And I think so.
I will all.
I want to just be a comic.
I did stand up at a festival and it was
so fucking fun.
I did it the night after.
Stan hopes.
Yeah.
Podcasts have material written down,
stuff about like this.
And I hadn't been the first time.
He didn't stand up.
And how long?
Well if you're not counting like the
weird like slam poetry music shows.
I did like five slash six years and then
it was the first time I've been on stage
in a year.
I mean,
so first time you've been on stage in a
year and the first time outside of,
because I saw something that you did,
uh,
were you,
you were doing like what you're saying,
look,
sort of slam poetry.
We take these big deep breaths in
between each line and your power.
It's almost a performance art piece is
doing the actual standard.
You don't pause,
you can't hear that.
They're not laughing.
My friend just,
you know,
you had a thing.
It was a cadence.
It was like I'm a drummer and also when
I wasn't getting booked,
like after nine slash 11,
my stuff was really political and I
wasn't getting booked in New York,
so I would just go to slam poetry places
and I just made,
if I had a gay rights joke,
I'm like,
oh,
well let's just do a three minute gay
rights chunk.
Right.
And so I started to get booked,
but at some of it was really well
written.
I saw this one thing that you did in
front of some big giant group of people
about,
uh,
the trump boys.
And uh,
oh,
that was at the Lib qualys show.
Yeah.
All this shit happened like right after.
Yeah,
it was,
it was a real bummer right after I,
I'm in La,
my.
Because I was suicidal in New York,
which I've never talked about publicly
before.
Before that was very,
I was very,
very,
very suicidal.
Here's,
Oh,
I was just in a,
I don't want to say like love,
I don't want to be mean,
but it was in like a failed
relationship.
Right,
right.
And I didn't have friends and I wasn't
doing comedy.
Why don't you have friends in New York?
I had friends when I would do Jujitsu at
friends of Marcello's,
like those guys were absolutely the best
friends I had,
but I didn't have,
I didn't feel like I had like a career
and I had a couple friends.
I mean all of our friends were pretty
much linked to that same sort of
progressive circle when I went home to
see my brothers and I could talk how I
want it to and I could shoot the shit
and I could like not police my own
language.
It was amazing.
I would,
I would go walk around blocks just to
talk to my brother Nick,
like for hours and we would just laugh
and tell jokes and shit like that.
And then I had depression forever and
I've been self hating forever and you
know,
this is not,
I can't by any means blaming on other
people,
but I remember,
and this kind of ties in,
this is really fucked up.
This kind of ties into what you were
talking about with like microaggressions
and,
and stuff like that.
I remember I tried to open up to
somebody very close to me about being
suicidal and they told me that,
um,
I forget the progressive word for it,
but they said it was like manipulative.
Essentially.
You being depressed was a minute of me
being suicidal by telling them I was
suicidal because I was telling them what
you're looking for help right now.
With that said,
the people who were like,
if you break up with me,
I'm going to kill myself.
That's fucked up.
Right.
That's like holding them hostage or
making them feel like they would be
responsible.
That I guess I would consider that's
manipulative,
right?
Well,
it's certainly not good.
It's not healthy yet.
Totally.
And,
but when you reach out for help,
but that's fucked up.
And so I didn't,
I didn't feel like I had a lot of
people.
I had my family and stuff like that and
that's why one of the reasons I moved to
La as I came out to here and I did a big
show and it was great and I love La and
I've always wanted to live here.
So once my relationship ended I was
like,
I've always wanted to go to la.
I'm going to go to La.
So I go to La and then the winter,
right?
Dude,
every New Yorker who's like,
oh fuck la,
they're all like,
fake happy.
I'm like,
no bro.
They're happy,
happy because it's gorgeous and like
we're eating Avocados by the pool and
it's sunny and everyone's really nice
interest was like,
I want to be in New York Yorker man.
And now he's like,
fuck that dude.
I did one winter.
I'm moving though.
He's moving back before this winter.
He's like,
I can't do it anymore,
man.
It's just cold and everyone's mean to
you and Jujitsu.
I don't like the main road,
so mean and Jujitsu in New York when
like in the winter where you'd be so
fucking cold and then you leave the gym
and you're so hot,
but you have your dumb jacket on and
then you have the subway and you have to
rip your jacket off and you got off the
subway and you're freezing again.
It's like that.
You know what the solution to that,
by the way,
it's non Vegan,
but reno wool,
Merino wool,
because Merino wool,
when you're wet to keep irritating teat,
it's uh,
it's a,
it also keeps you cool when you're
hunters use it.
It's around.
No Shit.
Yeah.
There's a company called First Light Lit
II and they,
uh,
they make like really Marino will
wool clothing for hunting and they're
one of the first guys to figure it out.
That's what it is,
is it's a natural fiber,
has a wool and wool.
It's a weird thing,
like if you have a cotton shirt on,
okay.
And you get wet from sweat,
like say if you hike up a hill,
but it's cold out and then you sit down,
you will freeze your fucking ass off and
it's really bad.
Like you can get hypothermia that way,
but if you have wool on it retains the
heat,
the buyer,
even if it's wet,
it's really weird.
So if you just were a,
um,
a base layer of Merino wool,
like when you go out,
like in cold weather,
you will get wet from the sweat,
but your body will retain heat to stay
warm.
Well now in la I got to pull up the
fucking Hensley was my little
preassembled chain.
Say Bye to everybody and get back in my
car.
Yeah,
it's fascinating.
Yeah.
You have to lay a towel down so you
don't sweat through your seat.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Totally.
So,
uh,
so yeah.
So I moved to La and I met my girlfriend
and it's like the most healthy,
wonderful relationship.
My poor girl,
my girlfriend was a comedy fan when she
met me and not a feminist and she saw me
at cobb's.
I was one of the clubs.
I would still like play me and I,
uh,
and when we first met I think she got
excited that she was going to date a
comic because she's like a huge comedy
fan dude and you know,
we moved in together and she would be
like,
you know,
is exaggerated,
but it would be like,
do you listen to bill burrs podcast?
And I'd be like,
Oh,
well let me tell you why he's
problematic and upholds the patriarchy
and she must've been like,
fucking shit.
But she's like,
I'm getting the kind of,
yeah,
kind of.
And now once all this shit happened,
I get to discover all these great people
I wasn't allowed to watch.
I'm like,
did you know that these woody Allen
movies are good?
And I've watched Manchester by the sea
and it was great.
I met you,
I met you.
You were deep in the throes or you were
beginning your journey of progressivism.
Yeah.
And you were,
you were on your way.
First show we did was great.
I don't think we know.
No,
no,
that's not what I mean.
I mean,
but what I'm saying is,
but I knew people that knew you from
back in the day,
like stanhill Oh,
right.
I remember what kills team is just a
comic.
It was just a comment because one of us,
and then he let you assume this
identity,
but um,
all of us are susceptible to ideologies
and be like,
Jordan Peterson had a really fascinating
take a nazi-ism about these,
these people that became Nazis.
And what's most terrifying about it is
that have you were in their exact same
shoes.
You are a human being and it is quite
possible that you could have been a Nazi
too.
And that is terrifying people.
But that obviously that's a very evil
ideology.
But ideologies in general,
we're all susceptible to them.
I've been susceptible to ideologies my
whole life.
And it's,
I have a very addictive personality and
I think that's one of the reasons why
you and I connect our on Jujitsu things
along those lines because you get
obsessed with these things and they
become a part of your identity.
And I think for you,
progressivism was in that box.
It was in that wheelhouse.
Yeah,
and we all crave acceptance and comfort
and support and a tribe,
right?
Um,
and so and again with progressivism,
it doesn't sound like an evil thing.
It's not like I was in a gang,
like no parents or warning kids.
Like,
oh,
I hear Noam Chomsky blasted out of his
fucking stereo.
Like,
that doesn't happen.
So you don't really does.
It's really slow anyway,
are really,
really slow.
He talks like this,
it's not a problem.
I tried to ask him a relationship
question just to change it up and he was
like,
I'm not going to answer that.
I was say that.
Yeah.
And I was like,
I'm sorry.
Wow.
I was trying to be funny at the end of
the interview relationship question.
I was like,
what do you consider?
It was like,
love or like,
what's your,
whatever,
like,
oh no.
I was like,
I want to do like love advice with Noam
Chomsky.
And it was essentially.
No,
thank you.
Yeah,
I'm wearing sweaters.
So goes.
Yeah,
he's,
he's got a very distinct area that he
operates in.
Howard Zinn,
I interviewed,
he was funny as shit.
Was it?
Howard was fucking cool.
He was spry.
Yeah,
totally.
He was one of his last interviews at his
house.
Surprise,
a funny thing to say what really old
dude dude.
Well that.
But that was the first thing I thought
where he pulled up in his little car and
he had his like whole foods bags and he
like hopped up the steps.
He's like,
come in and they'll get your orange
juice.
And I was like,
all right,
Howard Zinn.
And then uh,
he died a couple weeks later like it
was,
it was one of the last fucking
interviews.
And he was like,
that's where Matt Damon,
you still live.
And I was like,
cool,
man.
It was awesome.
It was super cool.
Like I did not see that coming because
he just was really high energy.
It was self deprecating and the
interviews.
Dude,
it was awesome.
It was really fun.
Going back to this,
one of the reasons why I really wanted
to talk to you is because I think that
this is this trap of falling into any
ideology.
I mean,
I know a lot of people that get really
wrapped up in right wing ideologies.
I think it's a trap and I think that
also this,
this tribal thing that we do attacking
people that aren't on that tribe,
it's a trap to him and you see it when
you get rewarded for it,
like Pz Myers as a whole career from it
attacking people and the other side
instead of.
I think there's a way to get these ideas
across where you're,
you're not going to piss people off and
I don't think pissing people off is.
I think there's certain comfort to it,
but there's also people gravitate
towards you because they don't want you
to do that to them.
Yeah,
and I know what I'm saying.
Yeah.
And I think everyone does that,
you know,
like pc,
pc.
I haven't been on twitter and for
everybody.
Like he was always really nice to me,
but the people he's also arguing against
her also kind of doing the same thing
too.
I had this fucking revelation today
coming into the studio when I was kind
of like worst case,
like battle planning.
I'm like,
oh,
what if he really hates something?
I say,
and we're gonna get into a fight,
and for the first time ever I was like,
oh,
I could listen to them and ask a
followup question like I could just
because that wasn't an option before.
Because you have your.
Especially when you start going on MSNBC
and these news round tables,
no one asks questions.
No one goes,
what do you mean by that?
Right.
Guys went on once and you were talking,
now this is,
this is one time I actually got upset at
you.
They're not upset at you,
but upset at the idea time to around the
eye.
You were going on after Charlie Hebdo
and you were saying that the cartoons
that they did was.
We were really racist and my thought
was,
it's so fucking what you know.
Even if they were racist,
these people got gunned down and killed
because of ridiculous religious
ideology.
This is what this is about.
This is about not being able to draw
Muhammad well,
and I think that,
but you got wrapped up in this super
progressive like defense,
but you're also.
It was so confusing to me because the
term Islamophobia is a very interesting
one to me because it's always used
essentially on the left.
It's very rarely used on the right.
Right.
And Islam promotes violence against
women.
It,
it is,
it's very.
In terms of like,
it's suppression of women's rights.
I mean,
it's,
it's very ancient.
It's ideas.
Most religions do.
That is a very uniquely suppressive one.
I don't know if you actually take the
Bible literally.
Did you know that?
Like the Old Testament,
the Old Testament,
I mean the selling your daughter into
prostitution when they're talking about
someone who is literally taking that
version of it in practice and killing
cartoonists for drawing Muhammad.
So here's,
here's what I think you should be able
to do.
Here's what I've been trying to do,
where it's like,
I don't understand why you can't go,
um,
why you can't go racist.
Cartoons are bad,
right?
And hacky killing them is worse,
You shouldn't,
you shouldn't kill people.
Or if you go,
you know,
that uh,
uh,
Islamophobia,
racism against Arab people who you're
just going to assume are all Muslim and
not just all regrets about Islam,
but exactly all like except same
versions of that homophobic that's bad.
But being sexist in the name of a
religion is also bad.
Right?
And I think this is what you were
talking about where it comes down to,
well,
you got to pick a side deal.
It's either everybody's racist or every
Muslim is a murder and it's like you
don't have to pick a side and,
and,
and post this fallout when I've been
like,
I mean,
here's the thing,
I've been healthier than I've ever been
in my life.
Um,
my girlfriend is fucking wonderful.
I wake up at like five and I meditate
and like Jiu Jitsu saved my fucking
life.
This literally saved my life this year.
I'm at being off twitter.
Being off social media has been fucking
great.
It's been incredible.
And getting to hear,
like getting to listen to Sam Harris'
podcast,
getting to listen to your podcast.
Hearing both you guys say like really
progressive things.
I don't think people know that,
but I think they do.
I think you were just in an echo
chamber,
but.
Well I think if you don't listen to what
you're saying is side.
Yeah.
Here's the thing.
No one's running either side.
No,
this is what's going on.
It's not,
it's not like,
you know,
you're,
it sounds like it's the dolphins versus
the raiders.
You know,
like one team has very clear outfits and
they're trying to move the ball across
this line.
You know,
I don't know what any of those words
meant,
but I guess,
you know what I'm saying?
I really barely.
I barely do no fighting,
but the idea is that these,
these sides,
they're very fluid.
They're moving around all the time and
they solidify with resistance and I
think when people hear middle or middle
ground,
they always see that as wishy washy or
you're not taking aside.
Yeah,
exactly.
But I.
But I feel like there is still,
there's good middle ground,
like the,
the,
the racism slash jihadism is really
good.
Right?
You can say that both are bad.
You can say the jihadism is bad.
You can say the fucking profiling
Muslims is bad.
I don't know what's so fucking hard
about saying those things,
but also in an attacking all Muslims,
what you are doing is solidifying their
position as well and you're.
You're making it very hard for them to
look.
All religions at one point in time were
extremely rigid and like you said,
if you go back to the early days of
Christianity,
go back to the inquisition.
Mean they did some fucking unbelievably
horrific things in the name of God in
the name of Christianity.
Now,
if you look at where the more moderate
Muslims are today,
you know,
I mean there's people that are reformers
that are still,
that's still considered themselves most
of their grant.
Yeah.
Like,
um,
you know,
I mean there's a ton.
I had Hirsi Ali I guess is not no longer
considers himself a Muslim,
but Majid does mentioned wanting a lot
of them who consider themselves Muslims,
but they're moving towards a more
progressive ideology.
This,
this is possible,
but it's only possible if you,
if you're not attacking,
see if you attack.
Then the more radical of that base,
they they lean to that and they lean to
reinforcing their team.
Well not only the more radical,
but even just the younger ones where if
you are a 16 year old Muslim kid in
America and you immigrated here because
your fucking family got bombed in Iraq
or Syria or wherever by us and now
you're being profiled and being called
racist names here.
It's like that's how you make extremist.
Yes,
and so it's not only as the racism
racist,
but it's also fucking counterproductive
and a lot of ways.
A great way to put it.
Yeah.
It's like you are all these wars that we
say we're doing to defeat Islam.
They're also creating a fuck load of
extremists who maybe would have been
moderate,
but now their houses in a rebel,
they don't have jobs,
right?
One hundred percent and they're just
like,
well,
I'm going to avenge my family and this
dude says I got to go to heaven.
So fuck yeah,
and this ideology and this,
this point of view,
it's applicable to this whole team
mentality that we do with right versus
left as well.
And that in attacking,
instead of explaining the positive
aspects of your positions,
attacking the other positions and
attacking an ad hominem attacks on
these people and attacking their
structure,
who they are,
attacking them as racist,
sexist,
homophobic,
instead of reinforcing the very positive
aspects of live and let live about being
open minded and being legitimately
progressive progress.
You totally.
And I think that one of the things that
I know I did and everyone I followed on
twitter did in sort of the progressive
world as you would like try to out
progressive each other.
Right?
So it's like somebody has a progressive
take on the news.
How do I make it like,
dude,
when,
when same sex marriage became legal,
people be like,
yeah,
well tell that to the People Bama drone.
It's like fuck,
can we just be happy about like one
thing or it's like they're finding ways.
Like everyone likes cory booker.
What can I find that cory booker did
that was like fucked up?
Or,
you know,
like the,
I feel like you gave another example,
but it's,
you know,
I mean that just happened with rose
McGowan a little bit,
right?
Like she did this really brave thing but
coming out against Harvey Weinstein and
then people are calling it like white
lady feminism and it's like the left is
never going to win if you,
you can't let the rape survivor come
forward without attacking her for not
being raped progressively enough.
Like,
that's nuts.
Um,
and I think that's one of the biggest
problems.
Everybody's trying to be the best
example,
right?
The best example of being progressive
and shit on someone who's less
progressive than you.
Yeah.
Or the most depressed.
Right?
And ramp up the radical aspects of your
progressive and the most depressed is
that we were saying the most oppressed.
And like for like a white guy like me,
it was like,
well I'm not oppressed.
I'm not gonna start calling myself like
saying your Kilstein like I'm going to
be the ally so I'm not oppressed.
Because twitter was a great tool and is
a great tool where we wouldn't have had
a lot of like really big.
I think social justice victories without
twitter and it became a really good like
which ones?
Well,
I think it became a good watchdog for
the police violence.
Right.
And specifically twitter and not just
all social media in general.
Do you think facebook is more of an echo
chamber?
Like what do you mean?
Facebook?
I kind of just.
I mean at least for me a facebook goes a
little slower and I mainly follow just
friends on facebook,
but I guess you're right.
I guess facebook and twitter,
social media.
I think the problem with facebook is
that people have the opportunity to be
too verbose.
They can write these gigantic long
screens and no one's going to fucking
read it anyway.
You give people too much of an
opportunity to be self indulgent.
That's all I did.
That's all it is.
And then you just see it and you see a
word,
like you see a word like racism and you
go,
I guess I.
I Guess I like it because I don't want
to not like the big racism,
but then you also become item read
fucking articles.
If the progressive person I knew shared
an article and the headline looked good
enough,
I would share the article and then
that's the shit that happened to me.
How backfired.
Where I'm like,
how many people are actually reading
these fucking articles?
Reading the articles that say we could
not find that quote or we can not find
whatever.
So all this shit went down.
Jessebelle writes an article about you,
some other people write articles about
you and you just dropped off the face of
the earth.
So I just figured,
fuck this.
I'm deleting my twitter.
Yeah.
I said,
well,
I assumed.
I mean nothing.
I could say.
Part of me didn't say anything.
Part of me didn't say anything because
I'm like,
I no longer.
I have to be a real person now.
I can't do shows anymore.
So why did you say that?
B?
Just because I felt like the,
the only world I knew completely was
crashing down and calling me things that
I wasn't.
And,
and I already sort of burned comedy and
this is one I don't understand,
like I don't,
I don't see
big accusation.
We'll see them saying
fuck girls.
Well that's what happens is in my world
and former world pre,
you know,
Weinstein and like this is what real
predators look like.
It was just fun to go after him and to
go after me.
But also,
so as you said,
because you had sort of set up
rotted out myself.
Right.
And so my girlfriend,
when it happened,
my girlfriend was out of town.
I totally assumed she was breaking up
with me.
So I'm in La and like,
uh,
my little apartment,
my cat,
my girlfriend,
I assume has gone.
My family's talking to me,
which is great.
But none of my friends.
Here's something I'll say this about,
this is one of the reasons I came back.
The comedy,
um,
I mean,
besides,
I always loved it and I missed.
It was the only fucking people that
reached out to see if I was okay.
We're comics comics who I hadn't talked
to in years.
None of the progressive journalists,
none of the people who knew about
depression or suicide or whatever.
I mean,
I don't even know if they read the
fucking article like or if they just saw
that word and was like,
I will get in trouble if I mean Jim
Norton who I.
I knew when I was 22,
I probably asked him if I could do a
guest spot for him,
but like the stress factory wrote me to
see if I was okay like you wrote me a
really nice email.
Stan hope wrote me a couple of times to
make sure I was okay and prevents a wow.
It was comics,
comics,
real comics realize that we're all
fucked up
and I didn't go down your road,
but if I was in your shoes,
I might've walked on your road.
It's very possible and to say that you
couldn't,
I would never be in that position.
I would never do that.
I would never say those things.
That's disingenuous.
It's not true.
Right?
Right.
I,
I wasn't.
I didn't grow up in your house.
I didn't live your life.
I don't have your experiences,
your genetics,
your,
your environment.
I didn't have those things.
If I did,
I easily could have gone down your road.
Yeah.
And you know that definitely months
later when I reached out to Stan hope I
just reached out to thank him and I said
something that made him laugh and he was
like,
you can come back to comedy.
And I was like,
no,
I kinda,
you definitely could.
Well,
yeah.
And he was the one and man after doing
that festival and just hanging out with
like hanging out with just fucking Bert
and like a fun dude.
It was so fun.
It was.
So.
We do man.
We have fun.
Professionalist.
Yeah,
that's all it is.
And everyone's with this fucking podcast
is.
And you know,
it was crazy.
My girlfriend said this where we were
talking about this,
where those guys ball buster more
than anybody.
Right.
I walked backstage with my girlfriend,
a hug,
Morgan Murphy.
She said,
please don't rate me hug burt hug Bert.
He just said he's touching my dick.
He's touching my neck and started
running around the room and then they
had my back so fucking hard.
Whereas when I was around progressive's
were when Diana and I were,
were around.
They don't ball bust but they do not
have your back.
It is icy judgment pretty much around
the clock.
Will they feel like they have to know
when to cut you off if you do anything
though.
You crossed the line.
Right.
And it was,
it was so wonderful where I was like,
all I want.
So before that,
yeah,
I assumed I had nothing.
Was literally a to do know.
When you google how to kill yourself,
the first website that comes up is,
it's a lie.
It's they say like easiest way to kill
yourself and then you click it and it's
like,
just kidding.
Don't kill yourself.
And it's like heart music and you're
just like being rick rolled essentially,
but like a suicide hotline.
It's nuts.
And then,
uh,
let me kill myself.
But that's what I was saying.
I was just like,
I needed someone I could trust in my
time of need and they were lying to you.
And then I just started looking through
ways,
um,
where I was like,
I don't have a gun,
get a gun.
I would.
Now I'm Gunna win.
This fucking happened to get a gun.
I'm like,
I'm gonna kill animals.
I just fucking book listing.
How did it go from,
how did you stop being a Vegan?
Like what would happen there?
No,
I mean I still am like,
I ate a steak with Stan.
Hope.
Well,
but that doesn't count,
right?
Fuck.
It doesn't.
If it's Doug,
how many times have you eaten meat since
this all happened?
Uh,
not many.
I hate that.
I have to say be honest.
But I know I have to say,
look,
let's just go back to me being an
accused Predator.
I'll give you shit for that meet that I
killed personally.
You know,
factory farming.
You could eat that.
Oh yeah,
we can do that.
Maybe some of it.
Yeah,
I'll do that.
Okay.
Yeah.
See there you go.
Straight up.
You know,
wild has done it yet.
And through the woods.
No,
he's going to.
He's going to eat it here.
Should we all do it together?
We could,
you know,
but I don't know when it's gonna happen.
I can give you some meat right now.
Alright,
keep me posted on here.
I will have to commercial freezers back
here.
Yeah,
this place is fucking insane.
It's pretty well.
Yeah.
It's fucking insane.
Needed a fun house.
I'm so excited for like the mats that
comes this weekend.
Does it to this fucking great.
Um,
so this,
this whole journey that you've been on,
and this is again,
one of the reasons why I want you to
come on.
I think we can all learn something from
it.
I hope both communities learn something
from it.
I mean maybe it's wishful thinking on my
part,
but I really think like we,
this idea of right versus left is so god
damn crazy and we have more common
ground and we don't.
And I think reasonable people think all
these,
these core tenants that we were just
talking about,
like we think that we're egalitarianism.
I think that women should be treated
exactly the same way as men.
That you should be judged by your
character.
You shouldn't be judged by the color of
your skin or where are you from?
I mean,
how did the people that I know that are
cool people we have,
we have black friends,
we have Asian friends.
We don't like.
Especially in the world of comedy,
the,
the only currency that you carry around
is your personality and whether or not
you're good,
whether you're funny,
whether you work hard and when you're
around people that are funny and work
hard,
they,
those people are fuel
cute.
They're inspirational.
Totally.
And,
and I'll say this,
that I was not a good person.
I don't think,
at least to the standard that I would
like to hold myself when I was just like
wrapped up into this world and we were
very.
Well,
yeah,
I am flawed.
We all are.
But you are using a flawed operating
system.
Yeah.
And also like,
but I was just,
I was just desperately searching for
validation.
I was very selfish.
It was really depressed.
And ever since this happened,
I,
I don't fuck him.
I have not watched.
I barely watch the news when people are
like,
trump called North Korea.
Gay.
I'm like,
I don't know,
not to me,
like I don't want,
I don't watch that shit anymore.
You just stepped back.
I totally stepped back,
but ever since I sold a year.
Yup.
Um,
but I mean it wasn't,
I'm saying this right now,
like I'm like,
you know,
I'm just like walking the roads.
I quite Chang Caine.
I was like,
in the first I forgot about him.
You ever want to come through?
The legend continues not as popular.
Uh,
I fucked them quite as good.
No.
Well,
but I was like different times.
Yeah,
it was like,
it was,
he was still,
it was modern day.
He was still quite Chang Caine,
but his son was like a street cop if
it's the fucking.
It was the best.
It's so good.
And so,
yeah.
So the first year that kind of died with
a dildo possess a hanging by his neck.
Graduate Ham.
Yeah.
That was Carradine,
that uh,
that was,
that was not on the list of suicide
options that I looked up.
They'll know in the ass hanging.
They think that he might've done
something to piss off tie gangsters
because he died in Thailand and he died
like what would be considered either a
shameful way.
I mean,
it was auto erotic comics fixation was
what they listed,
but what I've heard is,
by the way,
that means nothing,
but what I have heard is that there are
people that consider the possibility
that he was murdered.
That's the craziest Shit I've ever
heard.
Um,
and put them in a wetsuit and shoved a
dildo up his ass and we'll look.
I can't,
I can't complain about my life anymore.
I didn't have a dildo shoved up my ass
by ty gangsters.
Apparently.
He wasn't a nice guy really.
Well that host,
like taking the show from Bruce.
I don't know how much he had to do with
it,
but like what companies like Bruce Lee
that was present,
he was probably just an actor.
Yeah.
I just like his people.
Right.
And nobody knew who he was.
Like no one knew who he was.
He had zero power.
Yeah,
that's very true.
Um.
Oh,
what I was going to say as.
Yeah,
I don't want to act like this fucking
hero who just stepped back the first six
months.
I walked around like I was accused of
actual sexual crimes.
I had a Hoodie and fucking sunglasses
and I felt when I would meet new friends
I would sit them down and be like,
just so you know,
like there's something I've been accused
of,
like I was fucking Megan's law pedophile
and uh,
it was only until recently,
uh,
my girlfriend's like,
you gotTa Stop Dude,
like are owning that.
You're owning that as like a,
a part of your,
your person when you,
when you do this.
And to a certain extent I have to write
like if I meet with like an agent like
and they google it and they don't read
it,
it looks fucking shady.
It's not,
but it looks shady and all people do is
they google and they look at a headline
and they go,
Oh fuck that.
I don't want to be around that.
Right.
But for the second six months or
whatever,
I feel like I've been.
My family is like,
this is the most present and
communicative you've been.
I feel like I've been a better friend,
my Jujitsu a skyrocket.
I feel like I have a family at my
Jujitsu school.
Like I've become a really good teacher.
I read more,
I fucking meditate more.
I'm like an awesome boyfriend.
Like I have such a good healthy fucking
relationship and I don't think any of
that shit would have happened if I was
still in social media world if I still
just woke up every day and was like,
what's the Hashtag that I have to tweet
about?
What are we angry about today?
Because that's how everyday starts as
you check twitter and you all.
There's a popular Hashtag.
I have to come up with a fucking joke
because trump did a thing and it drove
me crazy and there's part of me that I
am like,
maybe I'm selfish,
but uh,
I,
I just,
I would rather be a better person now
and try to be a comic.
I also forgot to like comedy fans,
just love comedy.
Like when people came up to me after the
Stan hope show,
I wasn't political on this Dan hope
show,
but they were like,
hey man,
that was really funny.
And I was like,
oh,
that's right.
Like you don't have to be overtly
fucking preachy or political to like
make someone's Day.
Right?
Like it sounds so cheesy.
Currency that you were training in.
I just thought you were trading and
progressive currency.
Yeah.
And I thought dude,
the best and if I ever did was a story
about my dad and I almost didn't tell it
and I was with Janine Garafalo who's
very political in New York and I was
telling her the story that happened.
We were just walking on union square and
she goes,
you have to tell that onstage.
And I literally said to her,
I go,
but it's not political.
And she was just like,
no,
you have to tell them on such a good
story.
It's about a relationship.
It's about,
uh,
your flaw is about what?
It was totally about me being flawed and
fucked up.
And it was the most enjoyable time I,
I had on stage was talking about that
and that's what I want to talk about now
is just like all the depression and
flaws and fuck ups and stuff like that.
Well,
don't be a human herself,
don't box yourself into some category.
And that was the problem.
Um,
but I felt like I could only talk about
that stuff.
You know,
it'd be like,
if you could only talk about like,
UFC and he'll talk about other shit.
Well,
I've been very fortunate that I don't
have to just talk about that,
but I think I've been very conscious
about avoiding weird boxes.
You know what I mean?
I've been stuck in some in the past,
but I think that you can navigate this
world of social media,
but it takes diligence and I think that
we're the first generation of human
beings that have had to encounter this
weird environment.
I mean this is not an environment that
our parents grew up in.
Oh.
So it's only if there's like a body of
information that we can draw upon.
You know,
it's not like a
lot of people have sort of figured it
out over the last hundred years and this
is how you manage the winter.
No.
Yeah.
Firewood and you got to do this and
you've got to make sure that you drink a
lot of water when you go into the
mountains fucking move to la.
There's,
there's no,
you know,
there's no history so.
And you become a real make mistakes.
You become really dependent on it and it
takes discipline,
man.
I was like,
I like logged onto my twitter the other
day for the first time to like follow
you guys and be like,
ah,
am I going to tweet anything?
And I didn't because I just saw those
notifications and I'm like,
there's some dark shit behind those
notifications that like of like I'm not
clicking it,
just can't be reading it and definitely
don't argue with people online.
There's no benefit to that.
I've almost essentially totally stopped
doing that.
Occasionally I'll fuck with someone if I
just am in the mood for it,
but the vast majority of the time my
phone is like this.
Oh yeah.
Face down.
I think,
I forget if it was like a jock or Tim
Ferriss or,
or one of those guys,
but talking about like,
uh,
put it on airplane mode like an hour or
two before you go to bed and then like
not turning that shit on until like,
I've started doing all that and I just
feel so much healthier and I'm telling
you that when I was attacking people on
twitter everyday I was depressed as fuck
and straight up suicidal and projecting
and she's miserable and that happens.
It's a rush.
You have a community,
you have people who go,
you tweet,
I'm having a bad day,
and you got 100 people being like,
dude,
you're awesome.
You know what I mean?
Like,
Shit's addictive.
Like it's really addictive.
It is.
And that's,
you know,
that whole sympathy,
mining something that a lot of people do
do.
Oh,
I did all that sympathy mining,
um,
you know,
virtue signaling.
It's like there's so many different
things that people,
just virtue signaling again,
uh,
I think it's what you've been doing for
other.
Oh,
cool.
Cool,
cool,
cool.
Cool.
Okay,
great.
So you know how it is,
I mean this,
this,
uh,
it's a really simple sort of way to get
love.
Yeah.
I mean it's a.
and then what sucks is like the
important issues also get pushed aside.
Like [inaudible].
This isn't like whether or not in
trump's coming go to jail.
What the fuck is you talking about that
before the podcast,
literally it,
was he going to jail,
going to jail.
I opened up cnn today for the first
time.
I'm like,
I guess if I'm going on Joe's,
I should know what's going on the news.
I'm like,
I don't know what the fuck is going on.
I saw Kevin Spacey,
I saw like people getting arrested and I
was like,
I'm out.
Well that Mueller goes not playing
games.
No,
he's not fucking around.
And he's,
it mean that guy was the longest running
head of the FBI since j Edgar Hoover.
He,
um,
and he is like painstakingly broke down
this collusion with the Russians
situation and what it seems to me as an
outside person who doesn't really pay
too much attention to politics.
If I was going,
I would look at it like the mob,
if I was going to attack the mob,
I would go after some low level people
first under at.
Yes,
that's what he's doing.
He's bringing in these dudes that were,
you know,
manafort and he's bringing
these,
these dudes that were running the
campaign and,
and,
and trump is unhinged today.
Trump is making a bunch of,
isn't it?
Yeah,
it's great.
But you know what's interesting too.
Then it just came out that Hillary and
the DNC funded the dossier on trump and
they spent millions to enlight about it
for the past year,
which is by the way,
that's you're trying to influence the
political process as well.
And you're doing it by what you know is
fiction,
fictional story on trump with hookers,
pen on people and Shit like that.
So there's everyone's dirty and this is,
I think really important.
I think the right has to recognize that
you're in a situation where you
absolutely have people that have
colluded with Russia the left half to
recognize you were in a situation where
you had a really corrupt career
politician who almost got in and don't
hold her up as some sort of high
standard for womanhood and progressive
ideas.
This is a woman that didn't even believe
in gay marriage until $2,013.
Dude,
I said that on stage when I was like,
wow,
when if you criticize hillary or that
people would say you're not a feminist,
and I was like first rule of feminism,
like don't kill a bunch of fucking women
overseas.
Do you know what I mean?
Like you can't.
That was another problem with like my
whole thing is we couldn't.
If you criticize a woman,
it would be one thing if you said,
I disagree with Hillary Clinton's
foreign policy,
that's not.
That should not be called sexist.
If you were like,
I disagree with Hillary Clinton's
foreign policy,
what a whore.
It's like,
okay,
well that's,
that's unnecessary.
But you couldn't.
You couldn't say she is a known lie
because they would say,
well,
that's a dog whistle.
That's what you call crazy ladies.
It's like,
no,
that's when you call a fucking
politician.
Well,
when they're crazy ladies,
you should call them crazy crazy lady
politics or just crazy person will not
be specific to.
Yeah,
and it's also like,
yeah,
like the whole Caitlyn Jenner thing
where it's like,
I don't hate her because she's
translator because he's kind of a cut,
like she's a little bit of a fucking
republic.
The thing about Caitlyn Jenner,
Caitlyn Jenner doesn't believe in gay
marriage,
which is fucking patently insane.
Right?
And that's what people need to know.
You're a bad person.
Ale,
Kardashians.
That's what it is.
Who became a female car dash in and got
what he wanted,
which is massive amounts of attention.
If you go back and look at Bruce Jenner
when he was Bruce Jenner and then look
at Caitlyn Jenner goal achieved
Katelyn's going at massive amounts of
attention.
People celebrating you're a hero.
You're amazing.
Same dumb person.
The
thing is I feel like you should this.
It sounds like such a.
like,
it's easy for me to say it because I'm
like a white dude,
but it's like I wish you could just
judge people as being people.
Now we have systematic oppression of
certain groups of people.
Right.
And I think a lot of people who say a
just judge people as people,
they're saying that while there's like a
black lives matter rally and it's like,
well,
not the best time to like say it.
Right.
Um,
but well,
the only reason why black lives matter
works at all is because it's an issue.
It's a matter doesn't work.
No.
Right.
It's a real simple.
Like the only reason why people go,
well,
you know,
we'll all lives matter.
Okay.
But no one.
See there's a reason why no one's saying
white lives matter.
Right?
Because the white people aren't being
oppressed.
And people were like,
if you disagree with black lives matter
as an organization.
Yeah.
Because it was kind of run by.
One of them was really not really a
black guy.
You know,
the whole Shaun king thing.
I don't know.
I think he followed me on twitter.
Shut up.
He's kind of a fake black guy,
but there's a lot of issues.
There's a lot of issues for sure with
racism in this country.
You have a group that addresses those
issues and the group gets attacked by
people you gotta wonder like,
why is that group getting attacked?
And I'll even bring this back to like
even with the rape culture stuff,
which I did not think I would be saying
on the show again,
which is that they're there.
You'd have guys online who every time a
woman got raped there'll be like,
well,
what about men who get raped?
And you go,
well that's awful,
but why do you say it when we're talking
about a woman being raped or why do you
only say all lives matter after like a
black kid was shot all the yeah buts,
yes.
Yeah,
yeah,
but,
but what about us?
It's like it can not be about you for a
second.
And I was just as guilty of that.
Like black lives matter when they go,
oh,
they're racist against white people.
It's like the title itself,
black lives matter.
That's a low bar.
They're just saying we exist,
right?
Like look at us like look at as being
gunned down in the St Louis being killed
by cops.
Right?
It's not saying the black lives matter,
therefore like white people should be
killed by cops.
Like there's nothing like that pool gets
so mad when it's not their group and
they always want to concentrate on
people that are black that make
ridiculous claims.
Like instead of just looking at the idea
behind why was black lives matter
formed,
then they start looking at black people
to make ridiculous claims like black
people can't be racist because racism is
right.
Our plus influence and prejudice,
which is just not read and that's the
same shit that people on the left would
do where they were just sort of like
nitpick at these very specific little
arguments and it's like there are bigger
things to fucking worry about.
Right?
Yeah.
And I think that's why an organization
like black lives matter kits any heat at
all because right.
If,
if,
if people just said,
yeah,
well course cops are absolutely shooting
black people at a disproportionate rate,
you know?
I mean,
if you just look at these incidences
that we've been forced to see in the
news,
there's been so many of them and these
people march and like what would that
one black woman who got pulled over and
refuse to put out a cigarette and the
cop was telling her to put out a
cigarette and she wants to be in dead in
her cell,
like a adult.
I think it was Sandra Bland.
Yeah.
She was just like hung herself.
That is a fucking insane story.
That woman,
that cop was a piece of shit.
I mean,
the way he was communicating with her,
he was not communicating with her.
Like she
was a woman that just got pulled over
for speeding.
He was communicating with her like she
was under him.
Like it was like he had.
He had to force his power on her.
I mean we've seen that kind of shit
before and if that's not racism,
it's absolutely shitty policing.
Well that's the thing.
That's what we should talk about.
And that's like what we were talking
about with the Islamophobia where it's
like you're also being
counterproductive.
Right?
Like you want to say that the cops want
to go with like blue lives matter too.
It's like,
cool,
why don't you guys should be the most
mad when there's Douche bags like that
who pulled over Sandra Bland,
right?
You guys should be the most mad to clean
up your fucking organization to clean up
your shit and you should be on the front
lines.
How powerful would that be?
Like them on the front lines with black
lives matter being like,
we don't want that shit in our
precincts.
And by the way,
it's not even just about the way they
attack black people.
You saw that woman in Utah that was
arrested because she refused to draw
blood on someone who was in a coma.
No,
I didn't say you didn't see that?
No.
Someone got taken into custody or
someone got to take to the hospital
rather.
Uh,
the cops showed up and demanded blood be
drawn without this person's consent,
which is against the law.
She said,
no,
the cop arrested the woman.
Now he's been fired.
But I think most people are unqualified
to be police officers.
That's a big job.
It's a big job and I think that there it
should be much more respected in which
it should be a much more difficult
position to attain and I think that this
here in lies the problem you're asking
regular people to deal with insane
amounts of power.
Literally the ability to pull the
trigger on a person and their life and
we've seen time and time again,
people get away with ending lives in a
way in a matter that we the citizens
don't agree with.
Yeah,
and the,
the bar is kind of crapped right?
Where now the things that you should be
using hand to hand combat for.
You're using tasers for the things that
you should be tasting four,
you're shooting,
right?
See,
here's the thing,
you can't,
you can't expect a,
the average police officer to be able to
use hand to hand combat on some person
when they have no idea what that
person's skill level.
Yeah.
Unless it's the cop is fucking steep.
Emile chick.
What is the,
what are the odds?
You're going to come out ahead.
You might get your fucking gun taken
away from you.
You might get shot.
Well,
I don't think they should have to use
hand to hand combat.
I mean it's fucking insane position or
at least be trained better.
Right?
Like people should not be dying.
You shouldn't be tasting like mentally
ill people who are writing articles
also.
There's a lot of like really frail
people that are police officers.
I've seen them.
Uh,
there was some.
God that was the other day.
They were pulling this guy over and they
had this guy out on the curb and I
looked at this guy,
he had a little pot belly and these
little skinny arms.
That's adorable.
Not really look at it like I'm like this
guy,
a victim.
Like if,
if someone,
if someone just decided to turn on him
and punch him in the head,
he would be unconscious and he's a cop
and he's like this frail
cop dude.
I used to have a friend who did
psychological profiles for people who
want to join the police academy.
And she told me some of the answers for
what,
why these guys wanted to be cops.
Like one guy,
she said literally wrote in his essay
like,
I want to become a police officer so I
can finally get the respect I deserve.
And it's like,
well,
I mean they didn't,
she didn't like,
you know,
he didn't go through,
but it's like there are those people,
not all cops Hashtag.
There are those people who are just
like,
there's one fucking power they want.
They got fucking bullied.
They got for every good dumb enough to
say that on his application.
How many guys just internalized.
That's what I was saying.
All that guy that it was not fucking say
that.
Right.
And like that guy was so nuts enough
that he's like,
you know what?
They'll,
they'll understand.
They'll see where I'm coming from and he
fucking wrote it.
There are so many fucking people that
they need.
I mean there's a lot of people that
don't want to be police officers.
Like in La for awhile they hit these
giant billboards where they're
advertising how much you get to start.
Oh,
they're having trouble recruiting and
shit because nobody wants that job.
You're essentially the professional
enemy,
right?
Pulling people over.
Most of them have committed some sort of
a crime.
They're going to lie to you,
so they're dealing with liars all day.
Jesus.
I'd ever thought about that,
but that's another thing where if you
also can't,
just like the cops should be trying
super hard to get rid of the bad ones.
If we demonize every cop,
then those cops who have like a really
hard fucking job are going to be like,
well fuck you guys.
You know what I mean?
For sure.
Again,
it's that it's that balance where and so
much of it comes down to just like the
economy and people's life sucking,
right?
Like it's really easy,
for example,
for people to shit on these like black,
like a inner city neighborhoods and they
go,
why don't they call the cops?
Why is a neighborhood trash?
It's like,
well,
because they called the cops and then
the dog gets shot or whatever.
Sure.
And so it's like people just need.
I think that's why you sound like trump
and Bernie,
right?
People need fucking jobs.
They want to take care of their family.
They're not reading twitter or the news
like I used to or that most of us,
most of us who live in this twitter
bubble,
all these fucking so many of these
progressive journalists I hung out with
who were like 99 percent,
like so many of them were like fucking
just spoiled rich kids who want it to
feel oppressed.
You know what I mean?
Dude,
you know,
uh,
I hang out with all my white journalist
friends were like white kids.
I'm like,
I see more diversity and fucking Jujitsu
than I ever did with the people who are
constantly talking about diversity.
It was a bunch of white kids trying to
feel more progressive or more
intelligent and I'm very much including
myself.
And then I started going to Jujitsu and
I was like,
ah,
that's what a Mexican looks like.
You know what I mean?
Yeah.
Well,
getting back to what we're saying,
I think that one of the good things
about these groups like black lives
matter is regardless of whatever
controversy,
it's forcing the conversation.
Do you have to have it?
You have to have that.
I just think they have to be careful
with
what they do,
like when kids get crazy and they want
to block off the highway,
you know,
they're like,
don't do that kind of shit because that
gives people a very bad impression of
what your organization stands for and
you're blocking off the highway and that
could stop people from saving your mom
who fell down and broke her head open.
I mean,
you,
you're gonna you're going to block off
the ambulance,
you're going to block off people that
are,
that have to make a flight.
You're,
you're in and you're saying,
well,
yeah,
that's how you make noise.
You know,
you cause people in convenience.
No,
you disrupt the,
the very systems that we need in order
to make civilization run correctly.
So you don't have to do that to get
attention.
So you're saying you still okay now.
Okay.
Got It.
Because the problem is,
and this you can blame on the media
where it's like those are the only
protest that get covered.
If you have a,
a peaceful protest with speakers,
you know,
standing out for at a south side of
someone's like congressional office,
then it's like that shit doesn't get
covered.
I remember going to hold on a second.
You're right,
the media,
but I think the media is slowly but
surely becoming irrelevant and the real
meat,
the real media is what's left.
The only reason why the news,
we don't even have to name an
organization in in quotes the news is
the news is because they have a long
history of disseminating information.
Right?
But people,
regular people are doing that now.
A lot of people are doing that now
through different websites and youtube
channels and I think that that's the
future and if we don't have to be,
as long as you're honest and you have a
real objective point of view,
you don't have to be sanctioned by some
gigantic corporation to get the fucking
truth now.
No.
In fact,
you,
you're less likely to get the truth out
because of your sponsors because of.
I mean Msnbc is owned by Ge.
MSNBC is the quote unquote liberal
network and they're owned by like a
company that like fucking profit off a
war.
Dave Rubin had a post that he did today
to go to Dave Rubin's a twitter page
about why people distrust the media and
why the media is garbage today in their
coverage of this Kevin Spacey thing
because all of these different outlets
were saying that Kevin Spacey came out
as gay.
That was the name,
the main headline,
isn't it?
You can't fuck a kiss.
Kevin Spacey came out as gay.
This was like,
well,
let's have a it up.
Pull it up.
That sounds like we should be
applauding.
Well,
this is.
This is.
It just shows you what it is like,
look at this media.
Why grow up?
Why doesn't the public trust us?
Because this.
Look at this actor Kevin Spacey Decides,
declares he lives as a gay man.
Kevin Spacey announced Sunday night that
he will live as a gay man and we look at
all these different than New York Daily
News.
Reuters,
the daily beast.
They're saying that he's gay,
but they're saying he's gay because a
kid came out where a man now came out
and said Kevin tried to fuck him when he
was 14.
So this is like saying that he declares
he lives life
as a gay man.
God Damn it.
That's not the store know.
That sounds like a festive thing.
We should all be like congratulations to
Kevin Spacey.
Not only that,
he said this in this statement where he
was apologizing for this thing,
so like this.
This is so crazy one also.
That's how they choose,
but choose to frame it that way because
someone coming out is going to get a lot
of people paying attention.
Right.
Well and also I don't have the link to
link pedophilia always to.
Homosexuality isn't true.
Like there are a lot of of people who
would consider themselves heterosexual,
whether it was in the church or whatever
who are raping kids because it's,
it's a power thing and they're sick or
pedophilia is just different.
Being attracted to kids is different
than being attracted to like,
like men and this is like also really
dangerous for to equate like uh,
trying to fuck a 14 year old,
which just like going down to west
Hollywood to like do some gay shit,
you know,
I mean he has admitted that he did and
he said he doesn't recall it at all,
but he did say that
he had a problem with drinking and you
know,
if he did do anything,
he was very sorry.
And we're talking about something that
happened at least 30 years ago.
Right?
So here's also a problem and this is,
this needs to be addressed because we
really don't know whether or not this
guy's memory is accurate because
something 30 years ago,
the problem with being 14 years old,
his first of all,
14 years old,
you're so God damn confused.
I don't remember shit.
He don't remember shit.
You are a wash in hormones and confusion
and insecurity.
And
he might've had something the last five
years of my life too.
He,
yeah.
he might've had some weird run in with
Kevin Spacey that may or may not have
been sexually predatory.
I don't know.
I don't know what happened,
but to to decide that he's absolutely
telling the truth and Kevin Spacey's
absolutely covering this up by coming
out as gay to using that sort of
diffused the situation.
Is this sort of
the.
This is almost the opposite of when
twitter declares you guilty.
This is like the news declaring you
almost like innocent,
right?
Where I don't know what happened to
letting a courts decide and talk about
people being accused and whatnot where
twitter can just like be like if they
say you're done.
Like you had a John Ronson on.
Right?
Did he talk?
Did he read that publicly?
Shamed looks good and it's just like,
man,
these people's lives are done.
And I was part of all that shit.
I,
I tweeted about fucking justine sacco.
Yep.
Straight up.
I did.
And I read that book and it's like,
yeah,
you don't,
you don't think of that.
You know what I mean?
Shot.
I mean,
that's the worst example of that is
people that are completely anonymous,
right?
You weren't completely anonymous,
which is why you face the blowback where
there's a lot of people that are just
have a twitter egg and they mean they're
completely anonymous.
They have a bunch of random letters and
numbers is their name and they fucking
attacked people left and right.
It's a common thing on twitter.
I,
we're seeing
a new kind of interaction with human
beings and this interaction where
there's no social cues involved.
There is virtually no repercussions for
saying the most evil,
vile shit.
And then people take it as a badge of
honor that they been blocked.
Right,
right.
Yeah.
And make it their twitter bio.
I mean,
so it's,
it's weird times.
Yeah,
man,
I just wish,
I mean,
being off twitter has I,
I wish it didn't happen in such a
horrific way,
but has definitely made me like I talk
to people more now.
I talked to people who disagree with me.
I'm like,
I look people in the eyes more than I
used to.
I like,
I'm not checking my phone.
Good thing to you all to ultimately to
because how else would you have escape?
I went live.
Yeah.
I mean it's almost like you were in a
cult because I had a,
a Bret Weinstein's brother Eric on
recently and Eric was talking about the
cult of progressive ideology that it
literally is a cult.
Like the,
one of the things that core things that
people keep saying is that biology and
gender are not related.
You know,
like there's some weird things that
people say in order to be supportive of
trans people.
There's a lot of weird but these,
these things that they're saying they're
not supported by science and they're
very culty and everyone repeats them and
they repeat them for the same reason why
people in certain religions repeat
religious phrases.
Yeah.
And this goes back to that progressive
thing I was talking about where,
you know,
to me it was the reason that I wouldn't
fully read a lot of those articles is
because I was like,
but I want to support those people.
Right?
And because I don't think trans people
should be discriminated against.
I don't give a shit where they want to
go to the bathroom unless it's like on
somebody,
right?
Like I don't care.
I,
I think that everybody should,
should live and feel free as long as
you're not being,
you know,
predatory.
Or like when the Republicans were like,
well,
men are going to dress up as women.
It's like,
that's,
that's men like bosom buddies.
Right?
Like that's like that was that like
trans people are different than men who
dress up as women and like sneaking the
fucking band,
going to be men who dress up like women
and seeking the bathrooms because they
can.
Because it's a loophole.
I mean they can just walk in the
bathroom.
It's just now though,
just like
there's going to be people that drive
into cards,
crowds of people with their car.
Right.
It doesn't mean that you shouldn't be
able to drive a car.
Right?
I mean,
you're going to have aberrations,
but it's not like there's a million
people right now sneaking into the
women's room to try to fuck kids.
I mean this is,
this is just,
you can't use those individual
incidences as aberrations.
No,
and so on awfulness.
Totally.
And so to go back to your cult thing,
um,
I do feel like you would have never
gotten out.
I mean,
I,
God,
I wish this wasn't the way it happened.
I,
I wish what happened?
Why?
Because look at you didn't get anything
wrong.
I know really bad,
no big deal.
That shit still exists and like
fuck did it,
uh,
like the fact that anyone would,
would think that.
I'm like,
fuck,
that fucks with you.
Well,
why don't you write a counter article?
So,
so I,
I think eventually I will,
one of the,
I mean,
one of the reasons I didn't say
published by like the men in this or
something like that.
Yeah,
exactly.
What's the red pill?
Yeah,
that sounds good to say guys.
I don't because I'm about to become a
fucking four Chan for Chan's happy with
us because we were making fun of the uh,
radio lab thing.
I got some tweets from people that
pulled down this thing where they shiela
above put up,
uh,
some stupid flag and said,
he will not divide us.
And four Chan went and found the flag,
it was in the middle of Tennessee and
took it down and walked up to the
caramel and fuck sheil above and it was
on his Webcam live and it was a great
way radio lab podcast,
but radiolab took it down because some
people complained that four chan is
awful and missing the whole point.
What they did was not awful.
These are individuals.
Fortunate is comprised of hundreds of
thousands of unique individual.
Fucking around in this incident was
amazing.
Yeah,
Shiela buffs a fucking Dork.
So the whole thing was great.
We could have come together with four
chats.
We missed our opportunity radio lab and
four Chan like as one for a day radio
lab.
Just,
you know,
there again,
they're there on that progressive
ideology team.
It's scary when you can't hear other
voices and there I think there's an app
they were talking about and Sam Harris
is show where it tells you if you're
reading too many,
like either left Wayne articles or right
Wayne articles.
Like it's like,
hey,
we're steering a little too left.
You want to balance this shit out.
And there's like an APP that can do
that,
now goes,
it aggregates your news.
So yay.
Yeah.
And will that just tells me you're
reading too much shit on your phone,
on your phone in general.
That's why I've started reading books
and it's much better and,
but fucking a.
I forgot I was going to say off of.
Oh,
the cult thing.
I mean,
I don't know because I still.
Yeah.
So I don't want to walk around a few
other way.
One of the reasons I didn't respond,
one of googling suicide and then I
shouldn't say this for my poor
girlfriend once she came back and like
had my back.
Like I said this on Doug actually
brought her up on stage for the podcast.
But she,
uh,
I thought she was going to break up with
me and she was like,
well I kind of wish you were more
predatory towards me.
And that's when I was like,
I'm gonna,
I'm gonna marry you,
you're great.
You're a keeper.
And she totally had my back and creepy
thing to say.
There's so many girls right now warming
up their fingers,
getting ready to attack a horrible
article was excited that his girlfriend
wants him to be friends.
She was kidding.
She's just funny.
She's a funny person.
You can be funny.
It can be funny and but fuck in.
When she had my back and like I kind of
walked it back and was just like,
what am I going to do?
There was another part of me that didn't
want to write an article.
I had people say to me,
I had one person who spoke at the
women's March who called me to be like,
this makes my job harder because when
you start to call
fighting with your girlfriend abuse,
when you start to call a a bad break up,
whatever.
When you start to call consensual
hookups on the road predatory.
It's like this is what sexist point to
when they go the APP.
All these girls who talk about being
preyed on,
it's bullshit.
You know what I mean?
They point to like these in innocuous
normal situations and so that's really,
really scary.
But I also had people be like,
if I defended myself and some people
told me this,
if I defended myself,
I would suddenly look like I'm saying
don't believe women or I'm saying that
because I'm defending just one person,
me and I'm like,
I didn't want to be and I don't want to
be.
I just want to be a fucking comic.
I don't want to be a voice for like,
bitches are crazy.
And I also don't want to be a voice for,
you know,
every guy is a fucking evil rapist,
right?
I just want to tell jokes.
I move on.
This experience in a lot of ways sort of
can guide you through it.
That's what's been happening just in
this.
Having this example of how it could all
go completely sideways,
sideways and sideways,
you know,
admittedly.
But even before it went bad,
it was going sideways.
Yeah.
We're attacking people without reading
the full story.
When I was depressed then and she
looking to get this sort of response by
attacking people,
gay people to say,
Yo,
Jamie's on our side,
James Positive total.
And then being addicted to this response
thing.
And checking your phone all the time to
making sure you know the people on your
side where you're battling with someone
and calling them as sexist,
racist shit.
How many followers this person has
just retweeted you like,
that's all I did.
And,
and now just being able to like,
like wake up early,
take care of myself,
read books,
hang out with my dope girlfriend,
go do Jujitsu all day and then write
jokes and live your life as a human and
just be nice to people do.
I'm telling you I am nicer to people not
being this like fucking progress because
I was just judging everybody.
How can you be nice to everyone?
You can just like,
look at that guy.
He's fucking eating meat.
Look at that guy.
He's,
you know,
he's got this fucking bumper sticker or
whatever.
You're just constantly looking to be
outraged.
Yeah.
The attack machine of this,
not just the progressive ideology,
but the,
the right wing ideology as well.
It's an attack machine and you can't
enjoy things like,
you know what I mean?
Anytime you tweet,
like I went to this movie and they're
like,
well this actor is problematic or this
movie is fucking racist because of.
And it's just like,
I don't know man,
I just had a good night.
I just wanted to go see a fucking movie.
Like I think that people are getting
tired of it though,
and this is what I'm hoping if you were
talking about this sort of balances out
and that this is a new form of
communication that we're engaging in and
people are doing it poorly.
Well,
and I'll say this,
I was
very surprised because I was like,
when I was taught,
when I,
when I told some comic friends that I
wanted to go back to standup or Improv
you people and I was like,
I was like,
no one wants to hear about my shit.
No one wants to hear a rant.
Being a moderate
and so many people like hush hush.
We're like,
yeah,
they do because they're sick of the
extremes on both sides.
They're sick of all this.
Like just everyone's just like,
all these trump jokes are just like so
fucking just it's white noise,
white noise.
So these progressive,
they're trying to out progressive each
other.
So people that consider themselves
progressives are also getting attacked.
Like the Bret Weinstein thing,
or do you mean he's getting called a
racist?
Like if you'd know him,
he's like one of the most deeply
progressive guys.
Like probably I've ever had a chance to
talk to why that was the rose McGowan
thing.
That was the guy I heard on on Sam
Harris's where if,
if something happens to a white person
than someone will be like,
well what did that happen to a black
person?
It's like,
right,
that would be bad too.
And it's like,
well what if it happened to.
And then someone else would be like,
what about a black trans person or
lensing?
The silencing thing is so fucked up and
this is what people are trying to do.
They're trying to silence people.
They're trying to get people fired.
But the,
the answer to bad speech is not
silencing people.
It's better speech,
right?
Isn't that one of the things that nick,
what's his name?
What is his last name that was on Sam
Harris' podcast.
I'll pull it up.
Well,
and I think that's great.
I was one of the really important things
that he said that I completely agree
with.
I will say that I do think both sides
say that like even when I was on not the
comedy side of the.
Of the thing,
right.
It's like shouting down at the female
journalists are trying to get them
fired.
Is still just as bad as complaining
about tosses joke.
You know what I mean?
Like it is both sides.
Trying to shut the other person down
instead of like a dialogue.
Nicholas Christakis.
That's,
that's his name.
Oh,
is that the guy who was talking about?
Yeah.
That's his name.
Sam Harris with the gross pop up.
Kill those on your website.
Dude.
Those are gross sinew for newsletter.
I'm not going to sign up now.
Sam,
you fucked your shelf with that little
pop up.
God,
I hate pop up windows.
This is the new twitter war.
Just Joe over.
Sam.
I love Sam.
Who knows?
I love him,
but I hate popups.
So he was the CO director of the aliens
too for network science and uh,
he wound up having to step down
if this is the,
is the CO director of the animals too
for network science.
So he was a,
he was a professor of social and natural
science.
Was this a guy whose wife also got into
trouble?
That's the guy.
Okay.
So this episode literally changed a lot
of my views on everything.
Yeah,
it was.
Well,
it's a very important episode in was the
name of the episode Jamie.
So facing the crowd facing the crowd.
It was about women.
This woman shouted him down and you
know,
you're supposed this is our home.
You supposed to be fucking protecting us
about Halloween costumes.
And the wife had made a letter that she
had sent out and then let her
essentially said you people should be
allowed to have like,
we'll play some of this here.
I hear that.
I'm looking at this record your face.
I'm disgusted and I'm sick.
Watching them argue with you.
I've been,
we've been standing outside literally
for at least five to six hours between
you and Holloway,
which we last night to now.
We've been arguing with people who are
not willing to be listened to for a long
time and all I see from you is arrogance
and ego.
I am sick looking at you.
I am disgusted watching.
Argue with you.
You are not listening.
You are disgusting.
I don't think you understand that.
And before I wasn't I before,
I was not angry per say,
I was disappointed.
Maybe I thought maybe there was room for
before an apology.
You've clearly told us that children are
plant.
Offer an apology for your words.
You left the meeting last night to go
home and then tweaked.
Do not interrupt me.
Two tweets from your twitter and then
the filaments.
Twitter,
you showed no remorse.
You tried to let your wife leave that
conversation without having answered for
herself.
That is disgusting.
That is sick and now I wasn't angry
before.
I was not angry before,
but now I'm actually angry.
Sir.
I really do not interrupt me.
I was not angry and now I want your job
to be taken from me.
I don't want to have this job.
I am disgusted knowing that you worked
at Yale University where I will get my
degree.
Well,
I will look back and think.
I used to argue with you.
Don't do it.
To not do it.
This is not the day you do not want to
play this game with or anything.
You don't wanna.
Play this game with me.
Okay?
I understand that.
Look at me in my face first of all and
understand that you are such a
disappointment to this university,
to your students,
to yourself,
to the things that you claim to agree
with you.
If you want free dialogue,
you want free speech.
This is how it works.
Someone speaks,
you listen,
you're not cut them up.
You did not do these,
these condescending gesture.
You not smirk.
You look them in the face and you wait.
You wait,
your turn.
I think napping is amazing.
I'm just so fucking characteristic.
The most upsetting part of that.
I think what upset me the most is she
has my poetry cadence.
It was like she was doing the same moves
and the same delivery.
Well she was just trying to be
intelligent and say something and shut
him up and sound sin.
But that's the most important thing is
that she didn't want a dialogue.
She wanted to be.
He also,
from what I remember on the podcast,
he didn't need to be out there.
He stayed up there for hours and talk to
those people are super reasonable.
So when she was saying like,
you're wasting my time or whatever.
Like he came out to try to Kinda like
have his wife's back and like calling
him like he came out to have a dial when
I hear them out.
But like he didn't fucking need to be
there.
What she was saying,
I'm going to have your job.
This is where I'm going to get my
degree.
And guess what fucker.
I mean,
I'll tell you this,
as somebody who lost their job and as
someone who has gone after people on
twitter,
those people that we tried to get fired
or from a writing job or whatever,
you think about them the next day,
like the people who tried to get that
guy fired on twitter or whatever,
like they don't think about him anymore.
If he got fired.
Those are kids.
I mean you're looking at an 18 year old
or a 19 year old,
but the twitter and intoxicated
intoxicated by that moment as well,
you know?
Yeah.
But the twitter mob behind them,
it's like a lot of me's,
a lot of adults too,
you know,
and like that dude got fired and his
wife got fired.
Like,
I mean that's,
that's like somebody's life who's done a
lot of really good progress.
They're saying even if he did fuck up
legitimately,
it's like.
And it's also the consequence of
actually being able to be fired.
That's a problem.
Like say if you were running a,
the Jamie Kilstein show,
you got your own podcast,
someone can't fire you,
you know?
And that's,
that's really important to be able to
fully and completely express yourself.
Yeah,
I mean if you had done something
horrible,
the marketplace of free ideas should
step in and say we're not going to watch
his show anymore when I got to listen to
him anymore and that,
that would be normal and real.
The problem with being a professor of
the university is twofold problem,
right?
There's tenure and tenure makes
professors arrogant.
It makes professors realized that they
can't leave and then they suck at it and
they're terrible.
I mean,
it's really common.
It's almost like winning the lottery,
like they become lazy and weak or they
become the idea.
Uh,
and the,
the ideal situation is they become
completely dedicated to being a
professor.
I don't have to worry anymore about
their job.
And so now they completely dedicate
themselves to being an educator.
That's,
that's what we would hope that they
don't have to worry about being fired.
Yeah.
And I really hope that the people
listening to this,
because I wouldn't have listened to that
podcast if I brought up that podcast and
my old circle,
I would have gotten in trouble.
Um,
I wanted to listen to a lot of your
shows and I'm sure there are people who
completely disagree with me
ideologically who wouldn't,
you know,
read whatever that the interceptor
democracy now or,
or,
or something on the other side.
And it's like my life has gotten so much
better and wider and vaster and I think
it's made me a more empathetic person
because again,
on the left,
you just assume you're empathetic
because you're on the left.
Yeah.
Even though you're trying to get people
fired,
even though you're going out for their
jobs and you're insulting them,
you're,
you're labeling them.
And the,
the broadest strokes of racism and
sexism and know you're calling them
terrible.
And that's the problem where it's like
framing and then that makes your larger
ideals,
which are,
can be correct.
They don't matter as more.
Yeah,
because you're not acting like I came in
being.
And then it's also like,
do you actually even care about those
groups you're defending or do you just
want to be on sort of the right side and
get your bonus points?
Which is like,
that's a big part of it,
right?
I would like to think I was both,
you know,
like when they turned,
I wasn't suddenly just like fuck gay
people,
you know.
But you did eat a steak right away,
man.
But it was a heterosexual CIS cow.
Most cows are actually dumped the
Navajo.
Yeah,
that's what a steer is,
is.
Yeah,
they,
they cut their balls off.
I got it.
But even that,
like I was emailing with,
I was emailing with Robb Wolf,
the big Paleo guy and it's like,
you know how much.
There's a lot of shit that vegans and
Paleo people could have in common when
it comes down to like hating factory
farms or like trying to get like the
healthiest like that,
like animal welfare and like,
I mean eating show many of the,
these Paleo guys are like,
the majority of what you're eating
should be fucking vegetables.
Sure.
You know what I mean?
And,
and,
and they're just talking about health
and they are talking about animal
welfare and that's so fascinating where
it's like,
oh,
those conversations will never fucking
happen.
Well,
what we've done,
it's a real problem,
is jam too many people into a small area
where there's no one growing any food.
And so to solve that problem,
they've figured out how to consolidate
massive amounts of growing into these
areas.
Both agriculture in terms of like
vegetables and grains and animals.
I mean it's all fucking gross.
Oh yeah.
What they do,
the way they grow vegetables is totally
unnatural.
You're not supposed to have a gigantic
swath of land.
No.
It's only dedicated to wheat.
Well,
and then all the steroids that they give
the do.
I saw a picture of a cow,
ones that I couldn't stand up because I
could utter was so fucking big.
It was like Wayne down.
Like that shit is.
That's actually a misconception.
There's,
it's very rare that they put steroids in
cows.
So what is it?
What they do do is they put a lot of
antibiotics in the cows because the cows
are eating things that they're not
supposed to be eating like grain and
they get really sick and they're doing
that to fatten them up to make it
bigger.
Right,
exactly.
And also that grain.
You could feasibly feed two people.
Yeah,
you can.
Sure.
I'm also the thing which was people
don't want to eat grass,
but the yield is much higher.
You know,
if they can get a cow,
they come to market quicker,
they grow faster,
but there are unhealthy there.
When you get a marbled steak,
like what's that?
Why goo stuff that people cherish and
love that Wagyu steak.
I'm the wrong person to ask,
but.
Well it's.
It's a really obese cow as well.
Okay.
But if you eat grain and you're a cow,
that's what happens to your basket.
I'll just get fat and gross chicken is
another one.
People always think the chickens are
getting pumped up with steroids.
Steroids are expensive.
What would they do with chickens is it's
really a breeding thing.
It's just like the way you make a
bulldog or the,
you know,
how do you improve the biggest massive.
They take the biggest animals,
they breed them with the biggest animals
and they've gotten to this position
where these chickens are so fucked up
because they bred them to be so large
they can't even stand up.
Oh yeah.
When they're like a clause like mold
around the cage and they're jammed into
these little areas to tough,
but then on top of that,
the real issue is that these animals are
on top of each other.
They're living in each other's shit.
They get sick all the time.
Yeah.
That was that super chicken.
That chicken is actually healthy,
but by the way,
you see it walk around.
That's just an enormous large breed of
chicken.
That chicken,
sesame street character.
It's a perspective issue too.
I'm sure if you were standing next to it
wouldn't look as big,
but I mean,
you know,
there's Turkeys.
Turkeys are pretty big,
but the,
the,
the real issue is antibiotics.
Antibiotics is a huge issue because
those antibiotics are,
first of all,
you get these animals like pigs.
The worst is pigs,
man,
because pigs are fucking smart.
At least chickens or reptile.
Yes,
they're birds.
They're brains are fucking tiny.
Baby pigs are like.
Poppies are so cute.
Heard.
There was a Glenn Greenwald article
recently that he published about these
people that got arrested because they
adopted these pigs.
They actually stole these pigs from a
factory farm and nurse them back to
health,
but in doing so and them getting
arrested,
expose the horrific conditions.
Oh yeah.
FBI's hunt for two missing piglets
reveals the federal cover up of barbaric
factory farms and that is a real cover
up because it's money and that's why
they have what they call ag gag laws and
I'm sure you're aware of these.
These AG gag laws are fucking insane.
Where they make it illegal for people to
take footage and film what's going on in
these factory farms because they think
they will negatively impact the business
and the farm.
Yeah.
It's like,
yes.
Yes it will.
Because you're fucking break here.
Your main.
You're denying people information.
Yeah,
and that deny people information like
that.
That was one of those issues that I
think I.
I think will potter,
I think I knew a couple of those guys
because mercy for animals has done a
bunch of those,
like undercover operations and stuff and
that's one of those things that again,
that that should bring together both
sides.
We're all eating these animals.
Right?
Or you're Vegan and you're trying to
stop this,
but you know,
no one for the most part,
it's like a fucking monster.
No one is like asking for like a
tortured animal like this who's like
rolling around in their own feces where
it's like everybody has the right to
know this.
This is something that I think the Vegan
community can be very mainstream about
and should get a lot of support and
greenwald to always been like a softie
for animals too.
Like he does all of his like snowden
stuff,
but dude has like 15 rescue dogs in
Brazil and he loves animals.
I know I'm,
I'm glad this is getting coverage from
these guys.
Getting coverage too and Kudos to him
for putting that out.
You know,
he's,
he's highlighting something that's a
real issue and that if that issue is
there's,
there's a concerted effort to deny
people information because that
information would change the way they
feel about the food they eat and you
know,
the argument is that these,
they have to have these conditions
because this is the only way to give
people food very cheaply because you
have to feed,
you know,
20 million people in Los Angeles.
But I don't,
I don't buy that article,
I don't buy that argument.
I think this is just how it's convenient
to run.
Right?
Yes.
And you also look at like,
what's the Shit we actually do subsidize
for poor people?
It's garbage.
It's like coke and like processed food
and it's like subsidized corn as well,
but,
but even that isn't,
that's not the best thing for,
you know,
especially like when it turns into like
high fructose corn syrup and shit like
that where it's like people need to be
educated doctors or barely educated
about nutrition and health and if we
actually had healthy food,
whether it be meat or vegetables or
whatever in these food deserts.
And so that's why I always got mad when
people were like,
oh,
look at that fucking fat person on food
stamps.
It's like,
well it's not because they're like
eating a ton of grass fed beef.
It's because like they're fucking food
stamps can buy them and serial and Mac
and cheese boxes and shit like that.
But that's another thing where it's
like,
well that's not a conversation we have
because we go,
you're either on the Vegan side or the
Saturday or the pro government or your,
your antigovernment.
It's like there are answers.
I feel like if people put their heads
together and weren't just trying to get
like,
yeah,
the guy who used the wrong pejorative
fired from the New Yorker or whatever.
It's again,
just like everything else.
There's more information available now
than ever before.
And I think more people are aware of
this information.
It's just so many people are distracted
by nonsense all day.
Like,
uh,
yesterday,
Tony and I,
Tony Hinchcliffe and I,
we did a Gig in San Francisco and when
we were coming back were at the airport
and we were next to this gal at the
airport and she's talking on the phone
about the most inane bullshit.
She's talking about amazing race and
amazing,
right?
The teams on amazing race are just not,
they're just,
I'm so annoyed with them so I'm not even
watching it anymore,
but oh my God,
I'm so hungry and this place has this
amazing Chiro and this is blah,
blah,
blah.
And I'm supposed to be getting this
thing at work,
but know so far my pay increase hasn't
come through and when it comes through
I'm going to save up my money and I'm
going to get this thing so mattered.
But this is what,
you know,
this is the average person's life.
It just,
they get distracted by nonsense.
They talk about bullshit.
They're watching stupidity.
One,
it's hard because it's getting,
it's getting fed to you and a lot of
people aren't doing what they actually
want to do and they don't believe they
can.
Actually do it and and they go to
college because they're told they're
supposed to go to college and then
they're riddled and student debt so they
get a job they hate that.
They'll stick into it.
Point was what I was going to get to was
that you in your obsession with twitter
and you're,
you're,
you're being addicted to it and
constantly checking in on it and going
back to it.
That was your distraction because my
first one was finding distractions in
stupid television shows and bad food to
eat and nonsensical raises at work and
because of that,
this occupies so much of your time
between your job and your family and all
this.
You don't have time to think about
factory farming
totally well and even now I can judge
that girl when I was doing the same
thing on twitter,
but I could feel like well minds for the
cause.
Mine's not for minds,
not for the amazing race minds like for
equal whatever.
And it's like,
well it's not,
it's not.
I'm not making a difference.
I'm just doing it for,
for a,
a little,
a fav.
I didn't even have a fucking twitter
followers to be addicted to twitter.
It doesn't mean you don't mean having
followers,
not what makes you did and anybody can
engage with a large group of followers
just by saying something mean to someone
like Glenn Greenwald or someone who has
a lot of followers.
It's not hard to do glen get shit from
all sides,
all sides.
You know,
once the Edward Snowden thing came out,
he became a lightning rod for it.
Right.
I mean,
there's a lot of people like that.
There's a lot of people that are doing
that.
It's a,
again,
it's,
it's a unique time for the distribution
of information.
It's a unique time because we have to
sort out ourselves how we manage this
information and where it's,
how it's kitten in man
say like once I just sort of started
focusing on in a weird way being
selfish,
like whereas like,
how can I just be a better person?
You end up that like,
I mean,
how can I better myself?
You end up being a better person where
I'm like,
I don't know what's going.
I don't know who's getting arrested
right now for the Russia thing,
but I'm like,
I know that like I'm picking my
girlfriend up from work after I like do
a bunch of Jujitsu at like a dope gym,
you know,
and I'm like,
I'm kind of fine with that,
you know?
Um,
I think it's just a healthier way to
fucking live.
Well,
you know,
you're,
you're talking about yourself and your,
you're talking about your own sort of
management of your life where it had
gone completely off the rails and now
you've got it back on track and you're
feeling yourself in a good place to
health and now it's like maybe there is
a middle ground.
Right?
And maybe there isn't
way that.
Like if I start doing shows again I can
like be on twitter and I'll be a douche
bag.
You can,
you definitely can.
And I think that having this negative
experience and getting through it,
that's how you learn and grow.
I mean these bad,
these big moments are big opportunities
for growth.
Whereas the same grind day in,
day out,
you become like the Gal at the airport,
it's like,
well,
these teams and amazing range here and
nine to put these chairs are their best
churros in their chairs.
Cheros are dry and boring.
You know,
there's nothing happening.
Having a big moment where all these
people attacked you and things went
totally wrong.
It gave you this opportunity for self
reflection and in a way that you're
really probably were very unlikely to
achieve without this moment.
No,
I was even going to.
I was either going to be off the
Brooklyn Bridge or a bigger Douche bag
and I don't know which one was worse.
You were at the all things comedy
festival.
You're hanging out with Bert and to
Oregon.
It was just literally the funniest
people on the planet and [inaudible] are
like the funniest people on the planet.
Doug on Ari.
He peed on him.
Right.
That might've been the day after I left.
I saw so mature.
I definitely saw red friends.
I've seen artistic.
Yeah.
I saw red deck.
I didn't see DAX.
Dax,
you know,
if I was in the wrong circles.
Ari could have sexually assaulted me
with his Dick by showing me his deck.
It would be considered some sort of,
uh,
my girlfriend pointed that out when he
came out on stage naked.
It's like,
would there be women in there that'd be
like,
that is sexual assault because I saw it
as a citizen's radio show.
You
definitely,
people would like,
they would be like,
their fingers would hurt from typing so
much to Jezza Bell.
It would fill the comments.
I wouldn't feel good about himself.
I a fascination with Meghan Kelly or
reject Jaza bells.
Daily breakdown of Meghan Kelly's name.
Retarded show.
Yeah.
It's,
you know,
man,
we,
we all,
we could all be nicer.
We could all find some sort of a middle
ground and look,
get all,
you know,
we could all learn from all these
experiences,
you know,
I can learn from your experience for
sure.
Yeah.
I guess that random women.
Well,
I'm not a Predator like a Hashtag.
You're the problem.
Know everyone's doing it now.
Uh,
yeah man.
I got to say like a listening to like
you and Bert and Doug and I started
listening to Fitzsimons pocket all these
podcasts about comedy and,
and,
and thinking about how,
you know,
just because I feel like I failed.
I was like,
I guess I shit on all comics and
forgetting about that.
Like even the comics,
you say the most horrific shit on stage
for the most part.
There's a lot of really cool broken
sweet guys who like through all of the
bullshit had my back.
Like I remember I heard burt,
I told burt this,
I think actually on the podcast,
maybe backstage,
but I told burt that like I was going
back and listening to a bunch of his
podcasts and I listened to the one he
did with metzker because I wanted that
other fucking side to it.
Right.
One of the other side's situation was
fascinating,
but you know,
to,
to.
I don't know if curt wants us to be
known,
but he was devastated by that.
I mean like really bad loss and hurt a
lot.
He was super unhealthy mean he felt he
felt it.
That he raged.
Man,
when they come after you.
Well,
and when I heard him on the podcast and
not,
he gets a little mouthy on facebook,
but when I actually heard him on the
podcast,
articulate what he was talking about,
where he was like,
no,
I think this.
So for people who don't know,
like some fucking dude at ucb was
accused of rape I think.
And,
and Kurt essentially said,
you know,
he made it sort of in parody saying that
no woman could ever lie and a woman is
like my Bible.
It's always true.
And Yeah.
But he was also saying that like UCB
said like they did an investigation and
found this guy guilty and he was like,
you can't,
you can't do it.
Like I don't know how to play an Improv
theater can like yes.
And their way to the clues.
Like I don't know how that happened.
Not Detectives.
No,
but now this dude can fucking,
if he is guilty he can like shoot the
ucb he like,
he can get.
And that's what Kurt was saying to where
it's worded it poorly and it turns out
that they believe the guy who is a piece
of shit and curse will be the first to
say that.
So anyway,
so I listened to badly.
No,
totally.
And so I listened to this interview and
that has to do with,
again,
just judging people on the Internet
without facts.
Right.
So I listened to this interview with
Kurt and burdens really good and I think
that was the first time I heard bird
show and at the end I was like,
ah,
alright the,
they started talking about me and they
weren't really wrong about a lot of the
stuff they said.
And I had this moment where burt,
who I only met once,
we did some weird TV show together and
like Amsterdam and I only met him once
and he,
I thought it was going to be like him
just being like this fucking faggot
feminist because that was the idea I had
of like all comics and how they thought
about me.
Right.
And he was just like,
yeah man,
I was just bummed out because I remember
like Jamie was nice and then like it
just like made me sad that he liked,
didn't stick up for comics and I was
like,
it was just like really sweet and
sincere and kind of like even like
vulnerable.
And I remember turning to my girlfriend
and be like,
I want to apologize to Burton more than
I do these women.
He sounded so sincere and sad and I just
forgot about that.
Like that,
that sort of comic camaraderie,
you know,
it's easy to characterize us in just to
lump us into this boarish group of
asshole men that are massage agnes and
you know,
you.
Did you ever see that thing where a Jim
Norton went on w Kamau bell and that was
Lindy West.
Lindy,
her characterization of that kind of
comedy was so caricature issue was so
ridiculous.
Yeah.
And,
and they're,
they're characatures of like,
like I know feminists who aren't fucking
insane and who like,
you know,
like she was wanting it to be a certain
way.
I think a lot of people do because it's
easier to eliminate,
stereotyped and demonized.
Yeah.
Because like you know,
it making that decision where I'm like,
all right,
fucking Rogan hates me.
I don't need to listen to that podcast.
Like I'll just get the information
that's easier to digest that.
That's cake,
right?
It's like,
cool,
I'm just going to listen to the shows
that agree with me and gave me
information that says you're right,
you're smart,
you're good.
As opposed to the stuff that's like,
ah,
I gotta look that up.
I have to like think about this.
I have to maybe change a behavior of
mine.
Right.
And people do that on both sides and
that's why it is so important where it's
like no one is the fucking stereotype of
anything that,
that people think,
well,
I think we're in a
boat that's in rocky water,
right?
And I think it's going to rock left and
it's going to rock right.
And hopefully we're going to right the
ship and we're going to figure out what
the fuck we're doing.
And I mean collectively the human race
has probably never communicated clear
ever and then we do now and it's because
of our access to information,
there's definitely going to be these
groups of people that so you know,
they,
they haul off and they get confirmation
bias and they made sure their walls up
with this group of likeminded folks in
an echo chamber.
There's always going to be that,
that.
But I think that is more obvious for
what it is today than ever before.
Totally.
And I think that's a good thing.
You know,
and I think that your ability to express
yourself like this on this podcast,
we've been talking now for two and a
half hours.
She is this.
Yeah,
this is a very unique way to
communicate.
I think this is a way to communicate
where you really get to know somebody
versus someone characterizing
uses.
Why have a problem with blogs?
When someone writes a blog entry on you
and you don't get a chance to respond,
they don't get a chance to see who you
really are.
No.
And then when someone like me who's in a
position to amplify it just reads that,
you just read it as fact,
just like you watch the news as fat
because you go,
well fucking called the news.
That's why it's interesting to see it
come back and bite you in the ass.
Right?
And then see your response and see.
You realize like,
oh,
and then go through this essentially in
exile,
period.
Yeah.
You know,
I mean you,
you went a year without performing.
I mean that's good without talking to
people like without talking to,
to,
to comics with,
you know.
But it was also like working on me
because like I,
it's not like the article was,
was garbage,
but it's not like I wasn't like a
Shitty,
selfish,
depressed in a bad spot person.
Like there were a ton of things I needed
to fucking look at myself and fix.
And,
and was I being selfish and wasn't
making this all about me and was I.
But it's not necessarily an accurate
characterization of who you are as a
person.
No,
no,
no.
But it was good for me to fix those
other things.
I was like,
well,
I didn't do that,
but I was kind of a Douche bag so I can
fix this,
you know?
Um,
that's why I,
you know,
I thought comics believed that,
believed that article.
And when I was talking to doug and I was
like,
I didn't read it.
No,
I know,
I,
they just thought it was funny because
I was talking to doug and I was like,
yeah man,
I,
I know,
I don't really want to apologize because
I reread it and I,
I don't think it's.
And he's like,
no,
none of us think you're a fucking
predator.
You're apologizing for being a Douche
bag.
And I was like,
oh,
I get it.
It was the,
the turning on comedy,
this self righteousness.
I saw the article and I,
I looked at him like,
Damn Joseph is going after Jamie
Kennedy.
And I laughed,
but I didn't think it was real.
And I felt like,
wow,
he's probably trying to get laid.
And he said something and someone took
it and turned it into some horrific
offense against all women and turns out
that he's actually a Predator and you
know,
fuck him,
he's cast out from the kingdom.
I mean,
that's just what people do,
man.
And one of the reasons why they do it is
because they're absolutely terrified
that they themselves are going to get
cast out from the kingdom.
Dude,
I have,
I totally,
totally.
Because everyone has their shit.
And it is.
I mean it like this,
although the Weinstein stuff and the
like,
there are a lot of due to probably would
be supporting this more butter just
like,
oh,
but I,
I flirted with that one girl at the
office,
like,
am I like Weinstein?
And it's like you can't compare the
Mustang because you have to go after
Weinstein with as much,
uh,
you know,
whatever vigor,
uh,
as you do not go after the people who
were fucking flirting with the Weinstein
thing.
What's unique about the Weinstein thing
is it is one of the worst cases you
could imagine.
Sort of like,
the cosby
thing is to drugging and raping.
It's like when you read about the number
of people that are accusing cosby and
you're like,
oh my God,
did he rape people for like,
this is like your full time job.
Next to the cosby show is a rapist.
Somebody characterized him as the worst
serial rape or in human history.
I heard you say that.
That might be real.
I mean he really might be.
He might have drugged and raped hundreds
of women.
We don't even know the numbers by the
way.
That's another fucking example now that
I think about it of what you were just
saying where the last however many years
he went from comic to lecturing like
black people about how to wear their
pants and how to articulate and he was
talking about manners and how to present
yourself and it's like,
oh,
you're covering up drugging them,
raping people where it's like you're
like,
you know what I mean?
That is what bit him in the ass because
Hannibal burress talking about him on
stage,
which in a comic,
that's what got him.
I still can't handle comic saying,
you know,
hey,
you tell me not to swear,
at least I'm not out there raping women.
People were like,
wait,
what?
What?
Like the average person didn't know.
No,
I mean I heard about it way back in the
day when I was on Newsradio somebody who
the fuck just told me the other day.
Oh my friend Curtis,
my friend Curtis,
his mom worked with bill cosby in the 19
sixties,
the 19 sixties and she was an extra on
something that bill cosby was doing and
someone pulled her aside and said,
be careful around him.
He's a fucking creep.
Whoa.
He will do something and you know,
I don't know if they specifically said
that they would drug him or the,
that he would drag her.
Oh my God,
be careful.
So people that worked with him knew he
was doing creepy shit like drugging
women in their sixties.
So we might be talking literally about
50 years up dragging rip 50 years of
drugging and raping.
And he did jokes about it.
Let's see.
I think curtis was talking about,
he had bits about,
about putting Spanish fly into women's
drinks and about drugging women,
actual bits about it,
Jesus,
but he got away with it forever until
this distribution of information that
we're experiencing now.
Yay.
And this is what would cause however you
want and that's why it's good and that's
why,
you know,
I would never be like a social media is
the problem because you know,
the,
the me too campaign and Harvey Weinstein
and Cosby like it is good that these
people are being exposed is not good
when you also then go on witch hunts for
people who like aren't like Dla fucking
rapists or whatever.
Well that's the difference and this is
the thing that a lot of men like they
see the Harvey Weinstein thing and they
start thinking about themselves and go,
oh my God,
what if every girl that I ever tried to
fuck came out and said,
you know,
John Tried to,
he tried to feel me up or John tried to
get me to go back to his house one night
after,
had a couple of drinks together.
And then,
yeah,
because what does that look like?
Is it a guy actually pressing up against
you and like violating your physical
space?
Or was it a guy being like,
hey,
do you want to come up for coffee?
And they're like,
no.
And they go,
oh,
fuck my bad.
You know what I mean?
Yeah.
And then how you characterize that,
I mean if you write a blog about it and
you take all these women that,
you know,
Bill tried to fuck and I'm going to say
bill because of Cosby,
say John,
John Tried to have sex.
Harvey.
Well now the crazy thing about harvey is
how many of them were famous.
Like these were like famous women with a
voice and he still did it to them.
Yeah,
I mean it's just like he just had some
crazy addiction to doing that to women.
It wasn't just simply like he was trying
to get laid off.
It's like you are a bad person because
you could get laid because you're
fucking harvey wind.
You are a very rich,
powerful man.
He could have hired prostitutes.
I mean,
if you wanted to,
if he just wanted sex,
it's pretty obvious that he wanted to
fuck the leading lady.
Yeah.
You know,
he wanted to stick his dick in the mouth
of the woman who was in the movie and
know what he's watching the movie I came
in her mind.
I did that.
Boy,
you don't want to get that rich.
You don't want to know.
It also was this new one accused of
raping employee in the Seventies.
Oh God.
As more women come forward.
It's a Goddamn rape fest out there.
Yeah.
But it's,
you know,
it's horrible.
Right.
And it also reinforces a lot of negative
ideas that women have about men too.
That's another part of the problem is
that they would go,
look,
we were right.
There is a rape culture.
It,
look,
we're right.
You know,
men do.
I'll do this.
Well,
and I think if people could actually go
after these rapists,
then again,
same thing with all of the middle ground
issues we were kind of finding,
right?
Where it's like,
well,
let's go after the actual bad guys and
then not make,
you know,
if there's a day where there's not a
rapist,
instead of like looking,
I mean statistically I'm probably wrong,
but like looking for like who can we
even be mad at for being sexist?
Just go enjoy the day,
right?
Like um,
there doesn't always have to be a new
bad guy.
Like you can just like go after the
legit fucking predators and,
and,
and rapists and there,
there's plenty of actual real targets.
Yeah,
yeah,
exactly.
We talked to you.
You don't need to invent that.
And also like is that the thing to do or
is the thing to do to try to educate
humans is to how to behave with each
other and that this,
this.
One of the reasons why this was he got
away with it is because he had this
extreme amount of power to control the
future of these women.
It was just that that's how he got away
with getting them to do these things and
keep their mouth shut because he held
this incredible power over them because
he could control their future career.
He had the money and the influence to
get them and give them the career that
they desire.
Yeah.
It was that legit casting couch cliche.
It's just like,
oh,
it was real.
And it was him and it was girls Whitney.
Cummings knows people that know,
like the,
the,
the whole inside story.
And she,
what she said is like,
what you're hearing is all the women
that said no.
She's like,
do you know how many famous women said
yes,
like graduating,
like I said,
to ask you mean,
oh no data.
Because it was a deal.
They made a deal.
This is how I get the leading part.
This is how I get,
you know,
a influence over editing.
This is how I get more lines.
So sorry,
get.
And that literally he,
they negotiated this.
She said he literally would negotiate
certain aspects of their careers with
sex and these women did it and you know,
some of them probably be grudgingly and
some of them willingly,
some of them happily,
who knows,
but it's just what you're seeing is just
this is how this guy operates.
Do you saw the.
Harvey Levin is his name who released
all the various aspects of the contract
that he had where they had worked in
some glass?
No,
he would get fined a certain amount,
like $100,000
for one,
$250,000
for this little,
like $500 for the naughty boy.
Fine.
Yes.
Yes,
like literally,
but negotiated into the car.
Look at this.
Here it is.
Um,
uh,
according to the contract of Weinstein
treated someone in properly in violation
of the company's Code of conduct,
which obviously means rape.
He must reimburse the Weinstein Company
for settlements or judgments.
Additionally,
you will pay the company liquidated
damages of $250,000
for the first such instance,
$500,000
for the second 7:50
for the third and a million dollars for
each additional instance.
Subcontract is like,
look,
you're going to get raped.
We know we know you're a piece of shit,
so we want to protect ourselves from
your piece of shit.
Place it is 100 percent known what the
contract says,
as long as Weinstein pays,
it constitutes a cure for the misconduct
and no further action can be taken.
Translation.
Weinstein could be sued over and over
and as long as you wrote a check,
he keeps his job.
Oh,
which is fucking crazy.
It's just like they made a deal with the
devil.
They knew what they were doing,
but he just had a pile of like rape
checks and can just dole them out.
It's just amazing that this went on for
so long and that they literally had
negotiated this into a contract.
Right?
I mean that is fucking.
But it takes that to change the culture.
It takes the cartoonish level.
Yes.
It takes that to change the culture and
then all the people that are terrified
of being outed like him now will
recognize the consequences of those
actions and hopefully they're gonna
change their ways.
That's what we're hoping.
Yeah.
I mean,
yeah,
you don't.
Uh,
but these are fucking say that you don't
like a rub your hard dick against your
employee.
Right?
Like you list your employee likes it.
Yeah.
And how do you know until you do it lies
the problem.
I was reading some fucking article,
uh,
another article,
an advertisement from,
it was like the 19 twenties and it was
an
advertisement for a type of like
antiseptic gum,
like a listerine type gum.
And the,
it was how to kiss a woman is that you,
you know,
you look in her eyes,
so do not ask for permission.
You just do it.
It's amazing like that.
But it just shows you the way our
culture has shifted from the 19 twenties
to today.
I mean a hundred years of progress.
And if people recognizing like,
hey,
no,
you can't just stare at a woman and then
fucking kiss her and not ask permission.
Like she's just like,
be confident and strong like,
no,
no.
What if your gross,
if she doesn't want to kiss,
you got to have more information.
Our product.
Yeah.
Sometimes here's the problem.
Sometimes that works.
If the woman is really attracted to you
and you're really attracted to her and
you look at each other and you don't
have to say anything and your tests,
but you don't know when the fuck that
is,
how do you know?
And you definitely can't put that in a
gum add humans.
But they didn't know that the 19
twenties because no one was there to
tell them like they were dealing with
the information that they got just from
communicating with their friends and the
people that worked with and the limited
amount of media that some dude was like,
yeah,
there was just some fucking girl.
And I kissed her and they were like,
got it.
How did you meet your wife?
Well,
it looked in the.
I didn't ask permission.
I kissed her and now we're married.
We have a happy family and that's how
you do it.
Like a fucking man.
Chew Gum,
chew gum.
But that was how much information they
had to go off back then.
Whereas today,
I mean if you asked me like,
hey,
how do you know when a kiss a girl will
there,
will he kiss her?
No teeth.
White and three shades of death.
That's a,
that's a different one,
but it was a yellow.
Add a mate upper left.
That's it.
Do you know how to kiss a girl?
Then learn.
Stand facing her.
Do not tell her your intentions.
Do not ask permission to kiss her.
Look dreamily into her eyes.
Look into my eyes,
Jamie.
Look,
let me see.
Dreamy dreamily my predatory.
No,
no.
You're dreaming.
You're looking dreamily.
Don't know how I'm not going to act.
You may hold her right hand and your
right hand if you wish.
It is well to cy.
A couple of times about this stage of
the game.
What?
What those per softly that her Rosebud
lips reminds you of.
Cupid's.
Bow.
Holy Shit.
Wow.
She will probably drop her eyes and
blush when you say that.
Place the fingers of your left hand
under her Chin and tilt back her head
slightly.
Draw her attention.
By the way,
this is all like you could see it in a
in a like you could see the cartoon of
it all.
One and the guys,
just like a cop,
draw her gently towards you.
Do not hurry.
Gaze deeply at the love lights which
slumber in her eyes.
Cy.
Once more.
Hold the sign thing of editing.
You need to edit this thing.
This is terrible writing.
Incline your head towards her until your
lips,
but wait all caps.
Do not kiss her until you know that she
uses lists.
Rated pepsin gum.
The only
antiseptic gum in the world.
The only chewing gum that makes it safe
to kiss.
Safe to kiss,
to your being a creep.
But then you're putting the onus on some
bullshit that's excess.
If she is a list of rated pepsin.
Gum Girl Kisser.
Oh,
that sound like a really bad penthouse
letter.
Not a fucking gum.
And 1911.
Copyright in 1911.
Comments since gum company.
So what is it common see common c o,
m,
but it looks like it's just a shitty old
font.
Blurry font sense,
common sense gun company,
common sense gum company.
Jesus.
Nineteen 11.
Well that's,
you know,
limited access to information.
Just the fact that that,
that would be torn to shreds if somebody
tried to write that today and put it in
an ad and like say esquire or something
like that.
Right.
But that's,
it just shows you the evolution of human
culture.
Yeah,
I mean,
and I think we're experiencing that
totally.
And,
and I think there's a lot of good.
I think like,
yeah,
that shit shouldn't happen.
You should just be creepy.
Sign into a girl's mouth.
That was bizarre works.
Here's the thing,
if a man and a woman are deeply
attracted to each other and she's a
moron and you're a moron,
you say more on things,
she's like,
oh,
cupid's bow.
And next thing you know,
wait a minute,
what kind of gum are you using?
Kind of gum shit.
Yeah.
I mean it says,
who are we to judge Jamie Kilstein?
That's should be the episode.
The name of this episode related judge,
no,
Judge Jamie Kilstein,
but you know Comma Jamie Kilstein,
or are we to judge?
I support that.
Who are we to judge?
Listen,
come back to being a comedian and
actually I want it back.
You're back.
I think I'm back.
Start showing up.
Still doing subsets.
Calling for spot.
I've got to figure out how to do that.
You'll figure it out.
I'll just start showing up.
Weird.
You'll get back in.
Get back in.
That's what I'm going to try to do.
That show was so fucking fun and being
around comics were so fun.
Forgot how much I love comedy.
My girlfriend's much happier and took a
break,
bro.
Yeah,
it'd be like,
why did you take a break?
And I'm like,
I don't talk about that.
Sufism got sick.
I got sick.
I got sick with the left.
Alright,
thank you.
Yeah,
no thanks.
I'll get back.
I'll get back on twitter.
Yes,
Rebecca.
Well,
I'll be careful with that.
Check my mentions that it worked yet.
Don't for a day that they will come for
you,
especially if they know you're
vulnerable bulbs.
Oh,
that's share.
Okay,
thank you man.
We did this.
Me Too.
It was great.
I'm glad I did.
Alright.
We will be back tomorrow with a colon.
Moriarty and a Owen Benjamin on
Wednesday.
See Ya Dude.